i have a vision for the world where
everyone has this kind of shared goal of
just making the world better yeah and
it's just agreed we've got this like
impartial goal yeah and everyone's just
willing to reason about it and
that's understood to be just like part
of living a good model life in the same
way as like not being a racist and you
know not like murdering and so on yeah
and i'm just like that is achievable
like we could have that world rather
than the world where it's like us versus
china and like yeah the you know the
whoa can the anti work and everyone's
fighting and i'm like no instead it's
kind of like like within ea is just like
you've got all of these people they're
like okay we want to do as much good as
possible we believe in like reason and
argument as the way of like figuring out
things and it's like people can have
disagreements but there's always this
feeling of like shared project and i'm
like okay i want to just expand that to
the world as a whole yeah and i'm like
okay how do we get there and then it's
like well one path on this and like
obviously i'm just trying to move the
world in that direction but one path in
that direction is hey friends and
welcome back to deep dive the ongoing
podcast where every week i sit down with
authors entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people we found out how they
got to where they are and the strategies
and tools and mental models and mindsets
and stuff that we can learn from them to
help apply to help live our best lives
what you're about to hear is an
incredibly exciting for me anyway uh
interview with will mccaskill will is an
associate professor in philosophy at the
university of oxford and was in fact the
youngest ever associate professor i
think at the age of 27 he got his
professorship there and his research
focuses around the idea of effective
altruism the idea that how can we do the
most good with our careers and with our
lives and with our money and he's
written this new book what we owe the
future which is basically all about the
idea of like how what what are the
things that we can do right now that
will help impact future generations
disproportionately highly this is an
incredibly long and wide-ranging
conversation we've not like normally we
cut down these conversations quite a lot
but we thought you know what we tried a
bit of an experiment and give you the
whole four hour and something long
conversation that i had with will we
covered all sorts of things from how to
figure out what to do with your life
productivity tricks we talked a lot
about the idea of long-termism and all
the different existential threats that
humanity is facing and what we as
individuals can do about it and just
like generally an absolutely sick
conversation his book has just come out
we'll put a link in the chat it's really
really really good and it's completely
changed my perspective in terms of like
understanding what are the risks that we
as humanity face potentially even
existential risks could we become
extinct in the next 50 to 100 years
maybe and there are things that we can
do about it so hopefully you enjoyed
this conversation as much as i did will
if if it feels kind of weird to call you
will because you're like a professor of
philosophy at oxford and you've got all
these like you're welcome to call me the
professor
yeah well professor i'm i'm so intrigued
by your backstory so you're you're the
like one of the youngest if not the
youngest professor
at oxford yeah so the little factoiders
at the time my appointment so it's 25 28
i'm in 2015 i was the youngest associate
professor of philosophy in the world
okay so at the age of 28 he became the
youngest ever associate professor of
philosophy in the world uh yep
and you founded well or rather you
wanted the originators of the effective
altruism movement your co-founded giving
what we can or what it's about 80 000
hours in in in various capacities how
did you become the youngest associate
professor of philosophy at oxford and
what does that mean sure
good dose of luck involved in that in
particular at the age of 22 when i just
moved to oxford to begin kind of
graduate graduate school i was just very
moved by the problems in the world in
particular i've been very influenced by
peter singer's arguments where the kind
of idea is that
we live even if you're in a middle class
income in a rich country like the uk or
the us by global standards you're really
in
you know quite intense luxury you have
something like 100 times the income of
someone in extreme poverty
given that don't you have a moral
obligation to be using your resources to
help the very poorest people in the
world
and he uses this story of imagine if
you're just walking past a child
drowning in a shower pond you see that
child and now imagine you know you're
wearing a very nice suit you're on a way
to a job interview it's a high stakes
thing
and the suit is worth hundreds of
dollars maybe thousands of dollars
and
imagine
that you just see that child learning
you think this suit is just kind of nice
i'm just gonna walk on by don't wanna
don't lose the few thousand dollars
in moral philosophy we have a technical
term for people that would do that and
that's being an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and the thought singer doesn't use that
term i admit but the thought is just if
you don't do that if you were to do that
you'd be an [ __ ] like the loss of a
few thousand dollars to you is just not
nothing in comparison to the loss of a
child's life
and that just really moved me so i'm at
graduate school i'm planning to be a
philosopher i'm working on like logic
philosophy of language like very
esoteric things that are very
intellectually interesting but don't
have a clear path to impact
and
i'm like i need to i need to alter this
i need to somehow start living in life
in accordance with my values
and it was there that i met toby ort who
was another graduate student at the time
and
it'd been interesting that i started
kind of shopping around for
a set of ideas that could really move me
and so you know i attended the socialist
workers party went to some climate kind
of activism rallies got involved with
vegetarian vegan society but a lot of
the ideas were
a lot of self-hate so sort of feeling
very bad about the problems in the world
and not actually that much action right
not that much thought about how much you
could you could do okay and then toby
was told me he made this pledge to give
away everything he ever learned about
twenty thousand pounds per year oh okay
and not only that he had started really
thinking about with that money that he
could give where could he give it that's
the most effective places that would
help other people the most
and so
he had this incredibly in-depth analysis
that was extremely action-oriented
and not only that he was really upbeat
about it he wasn't like oh i'm wearing
this hair shirt self-flagellating i hate
myself but i guess i must do it yeah and
said he was just like look this is an
amazing way of living i can live in
accordance with my values this is going
to be a very small hit if anything to my
own well-being but yet i can do enormous
amounts to improve the lives of hundreds
or even thousands of people yeah and so
we had this like five hour chat from
there i was completely sold okay
and honestly from that point philosophy
kind of took the back seat i you know
helped him co-found giving what we can
which encourages people to give at least
10 percent of their income over the
course you know every year over the
course of their lives until they retire
i believe that um yeah i'm a pledge i'm
a pledge of giving what we can pledge
pleasure whatever the thing is i made a
video about it a couple years ago thank
you for doing that that's just you know
a huge impact you're able to do and so
since that point then i split my time i
mean i was about a third on a kind of
academic philosophy i wanted to kind of
keep the option
options open but then the rest of the
time i was helping to build what
ultimately became known as the effects
of autism movement by setting up giving
what we can focused on donations then
with ours a couple of years later 80 000
hours which is advising young people how
they can use their careers to do as much
good as possible and i really thought
you know i'd always hope to be an
academic even since it's a bit
embarrassing like age 18 yeah
normally you have like cool aspirations
but i wanted to be a philosopher okay
and so i really thought i was going to
be making a sacrifice that was just
ending that as an academic year yep but
through some combination of luck and
being somewhat strategic in what i
worked on and like efficient in like how
i was using my time i was able to just
publish well and then get
uh yeah this position at oxford yeah i
feel very happy about and now despite
you know i had many years of living this
slightly schizophrenic life of being an
academic on one hand yeah then
something more like you know social
activist a social entrepreneur on the
other hand and now i've been able to
kind of blend the two where the work i'm
doing is both you know i think at like a
kind of high academic level
but yeah it's also squarely focused on
the most important issues love it oh man
so many so many questions along that
that's
firstly
what is a philosopher and what does it
mean to at the age of 18 to decide you
want to be an academic philosopher like
what what does that even look like it's
very funny when people ask me what i do
i'm like i still don't have a good
answer i'm like oh i'm a lecturer though
i don't actually literally give lectures
like oh i'm an academic people don't
know what that means yeah i'm starting
to find own it and say like i'm a
philosopher yeah what is that
what does a philosopher do i mean we
like the stereotype we sit and think is
kind of true
so i think
the closest to think the closest thing
is like what does a mathematician do
okay and a mathematician just ultimately
kind of
sits there they read proofs they read
like large amounts of mathematics
there's some cutting edge of thought
where there have not been further proofs
yeah and they try and like further that
and it involves a lot of like sitting
like pencil in hand you know trying to
figure out new proofs okay you can think
of philosophy as a discipline as
you know imagine like the entire sphere
of thought okay of questions you could
ask there are some questions that we can
answer with experiments sure that's
natural science yep there are some
questions we can answer with proofs and
that's
like domain of mathematics there's still
a whole bunch of kind of questions that
we can't answer with either of those
things so is there an objective morality
if so what what we to do and then lots
of the other class do we have free will
does the external world exist and so on
okay and
what can you do if you've got those open
questions extremely important that you
can't use a proof where you can't use
experiments well we've just got
the best we can do is kind of informal
reasoning so just very high quality
arguments clearly stating your premises
clearly stating what you're trying to
argue for and that most resembles um the
mathematicians sitting at a desk doing
proofs but what you don't have is
pollute you don't have proofs instead
you've just got arguments and so
you've again got to know the kind of
literature the state of thought on this
topic like you know what's the correct
moral view there's arguments back and
forth you try and generate new arguments
you've criticized others arguments yeah
you turn them into papers and books and
then you keep kind of having this okay
and then at some point along this
journey you start calling yourself a
philosopher slash other people start
referring to you as a philosopher that's
right i mean or is there like an
official qualified doctor that's like
yeah there's not a time even as an
undergrad people start referring to you
as a philosopher even though you're
studying i mean i guess the natural time
at which you can really say you're a
philosopher is when you've finished your
phd and have your first academic
position ah okay when you're officials
okay so it sounds like as a philosopher
you're spending your time essentially
basically taking a question which is the
sort of question you might get in i
don't know a university essay like does
free will exist exactly but actually
seriously tackling that question exactly
by reading all of the things that anyone
has ever written about it and then
trying to add your own flavor of
reasoning to that yeah exactly so it
might be you know there are these let's
take the example of free will well does
it exist you might think yes of course
it does like i make these decisions
all the time you know that's like one
argument it's kind of an appeals and
introspection yeah but then you might
say okay no it doesn't exist because
there's this argument that you take the
laws of nature you take the starting
conditions of the universe
if i had a super powerful supercomputer
i could predict exactly what was going
to happen through the entire course of
the universe it's actually not quite
true because of quantum
physics and quantum uncertainty but we
can put that to the side i don't think
it ultimately affects the argument okay
and so therefore if i could predict
everything that happens including every
single action of yours you don't have
free will
that's an argument that's a very
influential argument of course
and what the philosopher might do is
criticize it so they could say
okay the fact yes it's true they might
accept yes it's true that
in a relevant sense you couldn't act
otherwise than in fact you did yep
because all of your actions are
determined by
the laws of nature and the starting
conditions of the universe
however nonetheless free will does not
require you to have be able to act
otherwise than you in fact did
and would give some examples where you
give this kind of situation and you say
like look
this is a situation where the person
seems to be acting freely yet it's also
true that they couldn't have acted
otherwise and i can give you an example
yeah what's an example of that one
imagine that there are three people
we'll call them jones brown and smith so
jones wants to kill brown yep and he you
know goes buys a gun goes to where
brianna's living has his attention i'm
going to kill brown yep
smith also wants to kill brown yep and
smith has implanted an electrode
into jones's head such that if
jones were to decide oh actually i've
changed my mind yep have i kept the
names correct yes
john jones is the sniper yep jones is
the one who's going to kill that okay
yep smith is the neuroscientist yes who
also wants to kill brown who also wants
to kill it he's implanted an electrode
into jones's head exactly and
the electrode is such that if jones
changes his mind yep it'll take over his
body and he'll shoot plan okay
now what happens is that jones goes to
brown shoots him dead
intentional the elector never needed to
go off yep seems like that's a free
action sorry did does jones know that he
has this electorate oh he doesn't know
okay yeah yeah so from joan's
perspective he's just like i'm gonna
kill that guy brown yeah buys a gun goes
shoots him yep
seems like for the action if anything is
free yeah however he couldn't have done
otherwise if he'd chosen not to kill
brown yes the electrode would have
activated okay and his body would have
gotten taken over and he would have yes
shot down anyway but that would have
been a clear case of him not having free
will right if if his the electorate had
taken over
right so it's
if he had up to it otherwise perhaps he
wouldn't have free will however given
how he did in fact act yeah it seems
like you know if we're going to call
anything free will yeah that must be it
it seems like that's it okay but that
suggests that you can act freely without
needing to have acted
without it having been the case that you
could have done otherwise
got it so it's like even though you can
predict exactly what the outcome is that
doesn't necessarily mean that he didn't
have the free will to exactly uh execute
the outcome exactly yeah okay so that's
a sort of which invalidates the or
define argues against the argument about
the whole super computer analogy from
determinism exactly okay so instead
perhaps what acting freely is is
in some sense it being an authentic
decision yeah it coming like it you know
it being something not only that you
want to do what you want to want to do
but in some way a decision that you
yourself endorse yes and that might be
perfectly compatible with all of these
decisions being utterly predictable okay
so we just had a little a little one
minute taste of what philosophers do wow
okay and then you know the next round
would be people criticizing the things i
just said and back and forth how do
philosophers make money
but it's a good question most of them
don't make much money
i mean it's almost all and paid for by
universities which are ultimately funded
by the government or large foundations
is the dream for an academic to be a
academic philosopher to get tenure at a
university so that
their
sitting and thinking about stuff gets
funded by someone else exactly yeah so
when i had this first position about
half of my time was on teaching in
university admin and things like that in
a sense that's what pays the bills as
long as to some extent research funding
yeah but the research funding is like
very small in the grand scheme of things
uh it's now the case that i'm not on a
teaching position because you know
effective altruism is an area where
mobile philosophy is actually having a
real impact on the world it's advising
now how many you know billions of
dollars of philanthropic money are being
spent
and so there's actually like
it's particularly worthwhile investment
to be trying to get to clarity and some
of these crucial issues that affect well
really how can we do as much good as
possible with our resources yeah oh
absolutely okay so definitely want to
talk way more about like effective
altruism i have been a uh a fan and a
sort of proponent of the movement ever
since lucia who's sitting right there
told me about it in like 2015 when we
were in clinic in clinical school
together one thing i was going to ask so
you said your your friend toby donates
everything above 20 grand 20 000 pounds
a year to effective causes and he said a
thing that that would only be a small
hit to his
well-being
most people listening to this would
think
crap if i was earning just 20k
most people wouldn't be keen to accept a
20k job and they'd be thinking i need to
make more more money than that because
that will make me happier and a lot of
the studies that i have the pop
psychology studies that i've seen in
books say 70k is the point beyond
diminishing returns this where more
money does not actually contribute to
more happiness so where does this 20 000
figure come from yeah i can even talk
about myself so a few months after
meeting toby i made a a similar
commitment in my own case at least um i
can't speak exactly for toby i'll kind
of clarify it so that's
20 000 pounds post tax in oxford 2009
yeah so that's now about 26 27 000
pounds post tax in oxford okay like
taking inflation into account yeah and
then you know there's lots of possible
caveats and so on like if i have kids um
that would you know do this it's not
about me okay also health and so on yeah
but then okay what's the impact on
happiness yeah well
money does by happiness my best guess is
that just at least until you're at a
very high level that actually keeps
going up the study is saying okay it's
like 75 000
but remember that's where you just at
which it makes no difference at all yep
you're already starting to plateau yeah
yeah quite a bit below that okay on some
other studies it keeps going up yeah but
every doubling of your income results in
the same increase in happiness so you go
from one thousand dollars a year to two
thousand that's the same as going from
100 thousand to two hundred thousand yep
in terms of your increase in happiness
so then when you actually just look at
the studies and think okay
if i'm going from you know let's say it
would be a hundred thousand pounds a
year to this twenty six thousand pounds
a year yeah what's the like happiness
loss just from the kind of financial
loss yep and it's really pretty small
it's like i mean in my own like well
let's start off just looking at the
literature it's just like
a small increment loss maybe it's ten
percent
sure but i think probably not even that
but then you have to compare that to the
good you can do yeah and so
we can you know we'll talk about some of
the issues impact the impact long-term
future where i think the stakes get even
greater again
but even just looking at the amount by
which you can benefit people in poor
countries you can do about 100 times as
much good for someone else as you can
for yourself
because
there's two ways of thinking about this
one is in terms of if you want to
provide a certain sort of health benefit
to yourself so in the uk uh the nhs in
order to prioritize kind of what logs do
they fund or treatment do they find what
don't they uh they use a metric called a
quality adjusted life year it's like one
year very high quality health you
obviously know this as a in the course
of being like a doctor
how much does it cost to buy one year of
high quality health costs a hundred
times as much actually but maybe about a
thousand times as much if you're living
in the uk than if you're in a very poor
country like nigeria or burkina faso or
uganda so if i'm like oh i could spend
that money on myself i could spend it on
other people i'd be providing a thousand
years of healthy life to other people
and compared to one year for myself yeah
alternatively i could just think about
transferring cash yep because of this
fact that every doubling in well-being
every doubling in income increases
well-being by the same increment yep
and because of the fact that
a typical member of somewhere like the
uk or the u.s
is about 100 times richer in financial
terms than the very poorest people in
the world
my reducing my income by one percent
increases the income of a hundred people
by one percent
and that provides a hundred times as
much benefit and so that's the same a
second part of the consideration is just
and that's also just not how i think you
can even do the most good okay i think
you can get much bigger again phil
that's the kind of baseline and so
the thought i mean here's an analogy
it's like okay you can you're out on an
evening you can buy a beer for yourself
you can buy a hundred beers for other
people one of the other what you want to
do
i don't know i would feel like okay the
next land's on me yeah if it was really
that cheap but that's the situation
we're in at the moment it's a small you
know hit to your own well-being yeah
enormous benefit to others it just seems
like a really good deal to do that the
final point is just that all of that was
assuming that giving money is like
having an income hit like living like
just having a lower salary yep but it's
not
because
giving is a good is like enjoyable
itself so
if i think about what's been the impact
on my well-being from being involved in
effective altruism donating most of my
income
well
i have a much more meaningful life i'm
now part of this like wide community of
people who i just love and admire and
source of joy in my life it means that
like when i'm feeling down and like
you know not liking myself very much i'm
like well at least i'm doing something
like you know i'm really helping other
people and there's just this literature
as well on volunteering on giving gives
this kind of warm glow
and sometimes people give only for the
warm glow but you get it even if you're
aiming just to help others as much as
you can my honest guess is just that
like it's it's probably just good being
good for me off at all rather than
actually a well-being hit as i expected
it might have been okay okay lots of
questions on this front so
if i could buy
100 beers for other people versus one
bit for myself i would do that yeah but
there is a difference in practice
between the warm glow i get from being
able to buy beers for everyone in the
office than it is for me being able to
able to buy beers for people in
a far-off country that i will never see
in my life
this i feel strikes at the core strikes
out one of the issues that i guess peter
singer is like
very against and also the effective
altruism movement is like
whereby i know that intellectually i
should value the life of and i do value
the life or i should value the life i
would like to value the life of someone
who i don't know
as much as i value the life of my
brother yeah but in in reality that's
just not true and so
how how do you think about that thing of
helping myself helping my family and the
people closest to me versus
helping people that i will never see or
meet somewhere in the world
uh yeah so it's really tough i don't
think moral philosophers have a great
kind of answer to this i think there's
you know there's two different moral
perspectives one is the
you know impartial utilitarian
perspective which just says
well you know imagine if you were making
decisions about how the world should be
and you didn't know who you were going
to be in society could be randomly could
be anyone what would you do well you'd
want everyone to care about everyone
equally you'd want to have much more
concern for the very worst staff in the
world yeah there's another moral
perspective which says look no no we are
kind of
we're not behind this veil of ignorance
we're these engaged people we have
relationships that get these give
special obligations
i think in the way that the world is
today
there's not that much tension between
them because the stakes are simply so
high so for sure we can have these so
philosophers you're asking what
philosophers do they come up with
thought experiments they love thought
experiments yeah and they might be like
okay you can save um there's a burning
building you can either only save kind
of one group there's your brother and
one or there's ten people strangers to
you and another yeah a hundred people a
thousand ten thousand
probably at some point you switch yeah
it's not clear kind of where exactly no
when i ask people tends to be like a
hundred or a thousand yeah i was
thinking somewhere between that as well
for sure you may at some point in your
life face a very difficult situation
where your brother's life is on the line
and you can use a lot of money
and there it's just
a very hard model decision like given
the way you know the enormous amount of
injustice in the world yet also the
special obligations you have to your
family
however we're just most of us most of
the time are not in those situations the
decision instead is
do i buy this nicer car yeah or give the
money away yeah or do i go on this nicer
holiday or give the money away honestly
people just waste money most of the time
do i have a slightly nicer house those
are the decisions that i think we really
want to focus on at least in the first
instance yeah let's at least get to the
point where we're not officially
spending money on luxuries that
don't have an enormous impact on our
well-being yep and then once we're at
that point
then at least we can start having a
conversation of okay when it's a really
serious issue for our friends and yeah
like at what point does impartial
concern for changes make a difference
all right little quick interlude before
we continue with the podcast there's
this big ass book principles by ray
dalio people have recommended this book
for absolutely years but it's just
really huge and it's more like a
reference book than it is a book that
you read cover to cover so i've read
little segments of this book rather than
the whole thing and the way i found
which segments to read was actually by
reading the summary of the book first on
short form we're very kindly sponsoring
this episode now if you haven't heard by
now short form is the world's best
service that summarizes books but it's
way more than just book summaries
they've got one pages that summarize the
key idea of the book in a single page
and they also have detailed chapter by
chapter summaries that you can then sort
of dive into one at a time if you want
they also have these interactive
exercise segments in between some of the
chapters so that you can engage more
with the ideas of the book and even
better if the author says something
that's particularly controversial or
that another author has disagreed with
then on short form they'll include a
short form note which says that hey this
thing that radio said is actually not
entirely legit um like marie kondo or
someone disagrees with him and here is
what here is more details about that so
it just gives you a little bit more of a
balanced viewpoint of the book that
you're trying to read now for me there's
two main areas of my life in which i use
short form the first one is that if i
have already read a book like for
example steal like an artist then i will
often look at the short form summary of
the book just to revisit the ideas if i
want to revisit the ideas in the book
rather than rereading the book i've
already read but the second one is what
i did for principles by ray dalio and
that is usually if a book has been
recommended enough times something like
principles by raydalio and i'm not 100
sold on whether i want to read the book
or if i find myself short on time then
i'll often just look at the summary of
the book on short form and then
sometimes i'll decide whether i want to
read the book or not based on that but
in the case of principles i decided that
okay i need to have this on my shelf i
need to get this on kindle this is
actually a genuinely good book but right
now most of the points are not relevant
to me so let me figure out on short form
which point is most relevant to me and
then i can dive into the book and read
that particular chapter in a focused
fashion rather than trying to read the
book cover to cover there's nothing
wrong with this way of reading you know
i often think we should treat books more
like blog posts so please don't cancel
me for kind of besmirching the name of a
book by not reading it cover to cover
but i think a service like short form is
really useful in the sense that it
actually builds on the ideas in a book
and helps you engage with them in a way
that you might not have done otherwise
anyway if any of that signs up your
street and you want to get access to the
world's best book summaries more than
just book summaries then head over to
short form dot com forward slash deep
dive and that url will give you 20 off
the annual premium subscription so thank
you very much short form for sponsoring
this episode yeah yeah i think
in in my mind and certainly the minds of
a lot of people have spoken to about
this it's almost uncomfortable to think
that i bought thing x finger x cost me
three thousand dollars that could have
been the life of a child through the
against malaria foundation
let me not think about that and instead
think about the hypothetical scenario
where i would still choose to save my
brother rather than 100 100 strangers
and in a way the extreme case is a very
good easy it's easy
obviously in that case like i'm not that
utilitarian exactly and something that
people often get wrong about effective
alchemism is that
in economist language we're talking
about what we do on the margin or like
say we take the world as it is you make
a small difference like or how you're
spending your money like this you know
competitively small change does that
make sense not
how should the entire world be different
where you know people say oh if everyone
was funding bed nets no one would be
funding the arts
wouldn't that be a worse world i'm like
let's have that conversation
once we've increased kind of you know
global funding for
global health and development
up from you know i mean it's a few
hundred billion per year but it could be
much more than that yeah once we've
elaborated extreme poverty and we could
do that while still having enormous
funding for the arts yeah let's then
have that conversation similarly with
some of the causes we prioritize you
know maybe we say like this particular
area i don't know let's say it's
pandemic prevention yeah i'm saying look
this is a really top priority we need to
be funding it more and if someone says
like oh well what about other cause like
climate change or um education or
something is that you saying that's less
important
and the main thing is like
it could well be more important or as
important but if it gets like a
thousandth of the current funding then
on the margin
given the way society is currently
prioritizing we want a bit more of this
thing and that's why it becomes the most
important priority at the current time
so kind of yeah
the way in which you like we should be
like nudging the world at the moment
doesn't in and of itself has let have a
lesson for how should the world be
constructed in an ideal kind of an ideal
society yeah
oh yeah that's good i was actually
giving a talk at the oxford union like
two weeks ago one of the questions i got
afterwards was i left medicine to pursue
other things and in a video where i
talked about why i left medicine i sort
of the the fourth thing on my list other
than money and enjoyment and autonomy
was impact yeah and i talked about the
impact of an individual doctor cited the
article on 80 000 hours about this
talked about my
different sort of impact at making a
youtube video that encourages x number
of people to take the giving what we can
pledge and the
you know how how i convince myself that
that analysis is reasonable and it is a
reasonable decision or at least not
morally reprehensible to leave medicine
for the sake of making youtube videos
which would at first glance otherwise
seem to be a morally reprehensible
decision but someone asked they're like
well
if you encouraged all of the uh if every
doctor thought like you you'd end up
with no doctors and then that would be
bad i was like
i don't think we're there yet we don't
need to like yeah yeah so i've been
asked the same question my response is
just if only i were that persuasive yeah
and like obviously
that would be a terrible situation but
we're very very very far away from that
and so again it's just kind of what is
what is the world as a whole over
prioritizing and under prioritizing okay
and at the moment i'm claiming we're
over prioritizing you know philanthropic
spending on the arts and opera or causes
that are focused on um issues affecting
people in rich countries rather than
issues affecting yes people in poor
countries and as we'll get onto later
under prioritizing issues that impact
the you know whole course of
future stuff
i would love to hear your philosopher's
take on this if we accept that the
argument of if everyone did x then
then that would be bad is not
necessarily valid for encouraging a
small number of people to do x can i use
the same argument to say i don't want to
recycle my
tin can of coke because and someone else
would be like yeah but if everyone
thought like you then we'd end up with
so much more whatever in the environment
and i would say but they don't and like
unless china and india and stuff us
change their industrial stuff like my in
contribution to climate change is very
is very negligible yep it's a very
unpopular view i mentioned it in a video
one time and i got lambasted in the
comments for being being a terrible
person yeah but i wonder like what would
be the philosopher's argument or like in
my mind i don't currently have a
consistent reason as to why i as an
individual should waste my time waste my
time to vote or to recycle when i could
theoretically be making a youtube video
in that time that sure theoretically
reaches more people and has
theoretically more impact so i think in
a lot of these cases where
it seems like oh my action as an
individual doesn't matter i think
actually it does oh okay at least in
expectation uh so we're gonna use some
nice yeah a little bit of math that's
very helpful yeah so let's take the
example of voting yes so you might
actually think one vote doesn't make a
difference
um it's gonna be the same outcome either
way yep and probably that's true
but not certain
yeah sure
your vote like sometimes votes are very
close yeah um sometimes they can go to a
recount the votes that like who wins is
just the totality of individual votes
that people have made
and so for sure the chance of your vote
swinging the election is very very small
but
if you do that's a truly huge impact yep
i mean the gdp of the uk is three
trillion pounds per year something like
that the governmental spending as a
whole must be about trillion government
makes enormous decisions should we stay
in the eu
you know decisions affecting all of our
lives
once you do the maths
i actually think voting comes out as
quite a high impact activity it depends
on where exactly you live so if you're
voting in a very very safe seat yep
perhaps it just is astronomically
unlikely that your vote is going to make
the difference but if it's competitive
and the analysis has normally been done
in the u.s if it's competitive and if
you're pretty confident that you've got
a better guess about who's going to be
the better leadership than the general
public or the kind of media and voter
yep then
once you take the very very low
probability of making a difference
multiplied by the enormous value if you
do have a difference yeah that's called
multiplying those two things together
it's called the expected value
then it comes out that voting is like
donating tens of thousands of dollars to
charity
so it actually comes out really pretty
well okay and it varies from election to
election if you're in the uk i mean if
you're a member of a political party and
voting on who the leadership of that
party is i think that comes out very
good for other things maybe much less
but it does mean that voting can often
be actually yeah
is quite a good thing to do and i think
similar analyses can apply
to other things where people claim i
don't make a difference like oh if i buy
the factory farm chicken
it'll just the stores will stock it
anyway i don't make a difference well
probably you don't in a particular case
but occasionally
the supermarket will order
eleven crates of chicken rather than ten
yeah and then you've made this like big
difference yeah in the case of the
cycling actually i think it's
clear though that
any of your elections are making a
difference even if
they're very small that's clearer okay
well i mean yeah so the best case for
the cycling is aluminium actually
because that's so energy intensive to
make that's the thing where you've got
the kind of biggest bang for buck within
recycling
but there it's just
it's not like
oh i have only some chance of making a
difference like there you're literally
just putting
this putting aluminium
into the cycling bin it goes to the
you know factory gets processed and just
does mean that like slightly less
aluminium will be created that's
slightly less energy usage that's
slightly more efficient okay now you
might say the impact there is very small
and perhaps there are better things you
could be doing with your time so let's
say you really don't enjoy
the cycling you could instead be you
know volunteering for high impact
organizations or working and making
money that you can donate to other
places perhaps the impact there is like
much larger and
my guess is that probably is but i guess
if i if i seriously think about that
like how many times in my life is the
decision to recycle or not recycle
actually swung by the fact that i am
currently in the middle of volunteering
for a high impact organization exactly
yeah so you don't want to kind of create
stories that are just kind of
self-justifying true but if you really
were in that situation you're just like
look every every single minute of mine
is just it's devoted to doing as much
good as possible yeah i just like i
don't have time to worry about the
cycling
it's fine yeah um but i guess very few
of us are actually in that position
going back slightly to two things we've
already talked about this idea of
you know
you could be making easily six figures a
year if not more because of your all of
the things but you choose to only make
only make 27k for example and donate the
rest so you are
you are taking a sort of material quote
hit on the sort of standard of living
that you could have and it sounds like
your two reasons for this were number
one it's not that much of a hit anyway
because whatevs and number two that that
money could be way be better spent
we're on the hell helping other people
and therefore sort of
number three you in fact feel better
about taking that hit than you do
about having a six-figure salary
absolutely and therefore it's not really
a hit in fact a net benefit to you to as
if you were thinking completely
selfishly to be able to donate 80k a
year to stuff other than rather than to
yourself to buy a fancier car or a
fancier house yeah so there's kind of
three aspects is it financial cost of
course yeah is it a hit to my well-being
and i'm like i'm not sure there's
maybe some negatives but there's a lot
of gains as well like i say having a
more meaningful life being part of a
community yeah but then the third thing
is
if i'm thinking not about kind of narrow
self-interest but just
given my values given like how do i want
to have lived my life if i'm on my
deathbed when i look back at my life and
the introductory of my life do i want to
be someone who
kind of went along with a crowd and
bought the like nice car and so on
because i thought it's like what i ought
to do when i was concerned about my
social status yes or do i want to be
someone who's like no there are certain
things i believe are morally important
i'm going to live a life in accordance
with those values nice and then it's
like completely clear that it's the
third and i like i feel really good
about it feels empowering can we talk
about feelings for a moment so what's on
your mind
here's the other thing that's on my mind
i often have conversations with with my
housemate lucia about this lucia is uh
the co-founder of an organization called
leap lead elimination exposure lead
exposure elimination project yeah is the
one which you have actually donated a
large amount of money to you this year
yeah i mean it's
small by the standards of their budget
or the giving that's going around it was
like yeah i split my um donations into
two and they got 50 of my donations i'm
a big fan nice yeah so she was in my
year at medical school she also
practiced for two years and then as a
doctor and then left medicine
instead of making to make youtube videos
instead to found this high-impact
non-profit charity thing which is having
great impact in the world like reducing
you know exposure to lead paint in
particular in the developing world lucia
has been strongly
driven by
the peter singer stuff since like the
age of 11 when she first read i think
the life you can save and
really found that it struck at the core
of her in terms of feelings that
i am sleeping in this fancy house and i
know that there is a child dying in
africa somewhere and she really feels
that yeah and when i first heard about
this stuff and uh
sort of she introduced me to the
effective altruism movement in like 2015
2016.
i
very much agreed with all of the things
intellectually but i didn't feel it
internally i didn't feel like i like it
it doesn't actually keep me up at night
that there are people dying in the world
but it seems to be a thing that
genuinely does effectively in terms of
feelings
i wonder
what
where do you stand on the i'm doing this
because i know it's rationally the right
thing to do versus i'm doing this
because
it feels like the right thing to do if
that makes sense uh it's a great
question and i think i'm a mix and i
also vary over time so
going back to age 22 a lot of feelings
like oh i'm really motivated by this
yeah it feels like you know intense
tension when i was deciding on how much
was i going to plan to give and thinking
about this kind of everything above what
was 20 000 pounds at the time
it was a tough decision it's a very
major decision and i actually just so i
had visited ethiopia before and that had
made things much more visceral in terms
of getting to know some people who are
living in extreme poverty but i what i
did was just i loaded up images on
google of children suffering from
horrific neglected diseases
and in course of making the decision was
just kind of looking at looking at these
photos and i remember one in particular
that still kind of
burned onto my retina of a child who had
lymphatic filariasis of the face so also
known as elephantiasis i think but um
causes these huge swellings normally
it's of the arm or legs but the child's
entire face maybe eight-year-old child
was like kind of swollen and looping
down so kind of very very gruesome image
i just thought man if my giving can just
stop that once like just that child like
putting aside the fact that you know
probably it's hundreds of thousands of
times that
just seems worth it to me and
so it seems like the way it feels to me
is kind of like the rational kind of
pushes like decides what direction i'm
going in and then the like emotions or
the feelings are like actually the
engine that are pushing me forward and
i think that's you know being true over
time as well
now it's the case that like i've
structured my life i'm really kind of in
a sustainable way over the course of my
life trying to do as much good as i can
a lot of the time it just feels like
oh i do my job but like
i'm like oh i'm getting tired you know i
don't know it's more like it becomes
like as if
i mean again you must know from being a
doctor like you're dealing with these
incredibly
[Music]
you know horrific situations you can't
be
endlessly empathetic all the time
because you wouldn't be able to do the
job instead
i'm sure you can speak to this but
becomes like a job that's how it feels
most of the time to me but still often
i'll have
things that you know come up again in
terms of suffering in the world about
animals and factory farms or think about
the threats that are
facing us think about how we really
messed up in terms of our covered
response yeah think about civil war
that's happening in ethiopia and it's
just like yeah it's
still really moves me yeah that being
said i do think we should always go with
the arguments like it's a mistake like
it's a fairly noble honorable thing to
just want to be you know oh and this
really feels me it really engages me i'm
just going to help this person yeah
but again take the you know case of
being a doctor imagine being in a
you know imagine being in a conflict
zone so you know there's someone who's
potentially dying over there someone
scheming in pain over there you know
what you have to do
exactly and that requires a little bit
of emotional distance but that's how you
help most people rather than just
immediately rushing and tending to the
first person you see
i've got another friend his name is joey
savoy i think you might know him oh i
didn't know you found her yeah he's
actually gave me a few questions to ask
you
about long-termism which which we'll
definitely come to i initially got to
know joey because he came on the podcast
the other podcast that i run with my
brother and we kind of talked about some
of the a ideas and the idea that he also
pays himself sort of the median salary
for the uk which i think is around about
like 20 20 something thousand a year one
of the things that first that about that
kind of thinking that seemed very
appealing is that you decide once you
create a rule for yourself and now you
don't have to worry about money whereas
i feel like for me
i don't have a number in my mind of like
how much money i actually want slash
needs
care to make
and so almost every day whenever i'm
like looking at numbers on my youtube
channel and stuff or thinking oh we've
got 20 people in the team but like we're
a bit uh everyone's over capacity should
we hire a few more and then it's like oh
but then there's this cost about money
and margins and then there's like oh but
over the long term will this business
crumble and will i end up i don't know
having to do
it's just like i go into this loop of
essentially thinking thinking i need
more and more money to have more and
more of a financial safety net
so that
i can then continue to do the thing
which i actually enjoy which is just
sort of making videos and doing podcasts
with cool people that help people live
their best life
and one thing that lucio was actually
challenging me on the other day was
if money if you agree that money is
instrumental i.e has no value by itself
and its only value is in the effect that
it has whatever that effect might be to
you
and you know the other thing you
actually want to do that you're just
thinking completely selfishly if i know
the thing i actually want to do is just
honestly if i won the lottery i don't
know 100 million in the bank or whatever
that number is
i would just continue doing the stuff i
do do podcasts i probably have a lower
threshold for just like flying to the
bahamas to be able to have a chat with
sbf in person
or whatever but i wouldn't be spending
some amount of my brain space concerned
about optimizing more and more of my
business in my life to make more money
for the sake of a safety net which is
all instrumental anyway and it's like it
kind of becomes a sleep and i like the
idea of just being like you know what
anything over 25k i'm just going to
donate so now i don't need to worry
about it i can just focus on the thing i
actually care about but how would you
advise me in the situation
it's exactly it's exactly what you
should do so yeah early on in my
thinking about this i was eating it more
like every day was a decision you know
sayings please
stand and do a cost benefit analysis of
what sort of cereal to buy
like like how many calories are like the
cheaper cereal versus more expensive
cereal is it worth it
you're just you're not having a good
time and so instead just
very occasionally like in my own case
you know it's just
i make a donation decision if the year
or two in fact um it's not value i make
these kind of lump sums other people
just do it the money never even enters
their bank account just goes to they
but very occasionally maybe even just
once in your life you decide okay this
is how much i'm gonna live on the skin
how much i'm gonna donate perhaps
occasionally you make decisions about
your career choice as well and then
after that you think okay i've thought
about this now it's not something i need
to worry about this about yeah it's just
very good and in your own case you know
perhaps you don't want to go for this
cap of you know 27 000 or whatever
perhaps you want to say it's
well you've already said 10 maybe you
want to go higher 20 50 yeah or you want
to say no it's a cap but it's above some
higher amount a thousand pounds figure
that out for yourself i would absolutely
advise you to do that maybe you take a
couple of days when you schedule
conversations with people close to you
um to really figure out what's the right
level and then
two things one it means you can start
like publicly talking about that yeah
much easier to make a commitment yeah
you're like oh it's now embarrassing if
i go back on this yeah and then yeah
secondly it just takes a lot of the
stress away one thing i worry about is
like
let's say i want to have kids
and let's say you know my mom always
tells me that oh you know you're saying
you don't care about making money right
now but just wait till you have kids
your views on this will change where i'm
thinking
but let's say that's in maybe five six
seven years or however long it is right
now i'm in a great position where i can
make a lot of money because the youtube
channel is doing well and so on and so
on so surely i should make hay while the
sunshines and make even more of a
financial safety net because who knows
five years from now when i have kids
will i end up broken homeless and alone
clearly i think there's some flawed
reasoning here but how would you well
again this is the sort of thing where
take some time figure out like how much
is a reasonable amount to spend on on
your kids yeah i think the median
expenditure per child in the uk is like
six or seven thousand pounds per year a
child but you know maybe you want more
than that it's fine make those decisions
yeah and perhaps that means you're like
yeah you're not giving as much as you
would otherwise be yeah perhaps or have
a
higher cap but make a kind of informed
decision about it something you can
think about now i think something you
can commit to now it seems to me that
there's this enormous marketing engine
designed to squeeze as much money as
possible out of parents in order by in
virtue of making them feel guilty yes so
we don't have this in the uk but in the
u.s like medical advertising is mad
medical advertising yeah exactly because
it's a private healthcare system so
you're on the subway these big
billboards felt like have you heard of
incredibly their disease x it could kill
your child
by this medical test by these thugs okay
they don't need to say it's like one in
a million chance or something yeah or
just plans as well like you know it's
like you've got to get the like nicest
possible plan a thousand pounds or
something
and it's just like oh because i feel
like i'm gonna be a bad parent unless i
do this and that's just like that's
corporations like taking taking people i
think and so i think you can have like
you can give your children like a very
nice life
i believe you should carve out money
like in order to be a good parent
but that's perfectly compatible with
giving a lot as well i mean toby in fact
has a child um she just seems to have
like a blessed life like perfect life um
and he and his wife are giving most of
their income so yeah it's like it's
perfectly compatible i think with
decisions like this actually it is just
about sitting down and taking the time
to
actually make an informed decision and
as long as that decision is in a way
like directionally correct it's that's
better than a general uninformed of like
where the the inertia tends to words
more and more and more and more for the
sake of more and more exactly so there's
a yeah there's a kind of motto that
people in effect felt often say which is
don't let the best be the enemy of the
good so you might think oh no i can't do
this because like oh i wouldn't still
wouldn't be giving enough so i'm just
not going to worry about it at all or
like you were saying like oh but i just
were to privilege my brother over and
explain just like okay fine but like
you're giving 10 at the moment yeah can
you give more yeah and you're like okay
20 percent he's like oh by ought to be
giving him what's like fine still 20
better than 10. yeah that's like you
know we're all morally imperfect we're
never going to be saints
that we're going to have competing
interests but like relative to where we
are now like how much can you boost up
the kind of helping others aspect yeah
and generally i think it's like quite a
lot on that note one thing that you sort
of alluded to is spending spending a few
days to at least think about a big
decision yeah one of the things you said
was the decision you make with your
career what's what's the deal with that
okay so this is huge so the decision you
make of your career for those of us who
are lucky enough to have a choice over
careers it's arguably the biggest choice
you'll make in your life certainly one
of the biggest choices and i set up this
organization back in 2011 called 80 000
hours we chose that number because it's
approximately how many people at how
many hours people work over the course
of their life so if you think
uh 40
40 years 40 hours a week um 50 weeks a
year say 20 000
choosing that number just to get across
like this is a big decision you know one
percent of that is 20 weeks you know do
people spend 20 weeks thinking about
like a beer like probably not like
certainly i didn't i had the most
shallow naive understanding when i like
blundered into graduate school in
philosophy yeah so the first thing is
just really think about this if you're a
kind of young person
and then the secondly is thinking about
it in terms of social impact so very
very many people
want to do good with their career but
they find yourself in a situation this
is certainly how i felt i've just like
overwhelmed what on earth could i even
possibly do and so i was like oh maybe i
should work in non-profits but aren't
they just a band-aid i could work for
the u.n like i need a six-year
internship six years work experience how
do i even get that yeah watch i'm just
completely lost
and so what 80 thousand hours decides to
do is just provide very concretely
actionable advice for people who are
trying to do as much good at least a
significant amount of good uh through
their career
and that's via a few mechanisms so there
is a podcast the 80 000 hours podcast
there's a website that has enormous
amounts of content on both how to think
about this in general and specific cause
areas that we think could particularly
benefit for more people working on them
and then finally one-on-one clear advice
as well so once you've read all of that
content engage with it yep
you know careers are very different than
donations because
a big part of it is what your personal
skills talents and how is that best fit
yeah a good fit for different problems
so this one and one advice can help
match people to the areas that actually
they're going to be able to shine in and
yeah are also very impactful also
perhaps set people up with mentorship
and
further connections
yeah i think i think the thing with the
career thing is that like
often the way we choose our careers is
based on oh at 15 i enjoyed maths
therefore let me do economics for
a-level cool that was fun let's do it at
university cool economics at university
all these careers companies are scouting
me out and now my options are investment
banking hedge fund or private equity
exactly in my own case it was like i was
good at math so i was like oh maybe i
should do math but my dad did maths
language and so i don't really want to
be like him so i'm going to do
philosophy instead which i also like and
then it's like
now you're philosophy you don't get as
many of these consulting firms after you
so you become go to grad school in
philosophy and yes that's where i am
this is your life i mean this is just
the entire course of your life and it
really requires kind of more reflection
than that and what people often do is
they ask you know fans family members
people they know
but like
having a good understanding of two
things one is just like the nature of
the labor market yep you know when i was
at university no one said hey you know
that you can do a coding bootcamp it
takes three months and then you can
basically stay off going to a six-figure
salary that just wasn't a meme maybe it
is more now yeah so there's a state of
the labor market yep and then secondly
is just the state of the world where
there's this idea that
oh well what you should do is follow
your passion
and there's an element of truth in that
which is that you want a good fit
between a job you can really excel at
develop mastery at and come to really
enjoy
and that's really important but this
idea that i'm born with like
oh i just always wanted to be a
management consultant that was my dream
it's never gonna happen you ask people's
passions and they say sports music
exactly those careers that are
enormously oversubscribed very hard to
get into
whereas i don't know i mean maybe
nowadays
the kids would say a youtuber is the
sort of thing they want to be but this i
mean through the course of setting up
these non-profits like there are tons of
things i found enormously rewarding and
interesting i would have never thought
of because it's not something i had
experience with like managing
fundraising like i hated giving talks
and so instead the flaming that we have
with 80 000 hours is
start off having an understanding of
what the world most needs because if
you're just focusing on your passion and
not paying attention to the world we're
going to have like
you know another sportsman or musician
or artist or something or like and these
things can be good but like if they are
it's kind of you've been one of the very
few lucky people yeah
instead think okay what does the world
really need is there a placing shortage
of people working on the next pandemic
or ai safety or climate change or ending
factory farming
and then secondly asking within those
top problems
what are the skills that are most in
need and then thirdly thinking and what
do i most provide where am i the best
fit
so that's the kind of difference in
mentality is like starting with the
world's problems rather than starting
with
kind of myself and my particular
interests yeah
one of the i think one of the the tricky
things i find about this is
it i think it always comes back down to
this balance of how much do i value my
own selfish desires to
make money have status
live in a nice flat in london whatever
versus what does the world need yeah and
what some of the stuff that i see from
my friends who are
way more into ea than i am is that
actually those things overlap like you
actually can have you can do good in the
world while at the same time having a
great time and loving life do you find
that it tends to be that there is a
little bit of sacrifice or is there like
once you've found the fit you're like
kind of just kind of going full speed
ahead on both fronts uh yeah i mean
there's definitely i mean for my own
case the thing that i have most tension
with is just how much do i work versus
how much leisure time the kind of
financial sacrifice is just
yeah i don't know i mean i'm also just
personally
it's like if i had loads more money what
would i spend it on like okay well i
live in this like slightly run-down
house with like housemates i kind of
like it i mean i certainly like living
with housemates maybe like
we could get the plumbing fixed more and
it'd be less yeah i don't know there's
some things but like it's not huge yeah
the thing that feels more like an
ongoing thing is just like
you know how often am i like working
weekends how am i taking like time off
and things and that's this but even
there it's like how often is that doing
something that's like hard in the moment
but like very rewarding overall you know
i could have had a life that
had like a lot of time off i could have
that life now in fact it's at least
unclear to me like would i be happier
with that life yeah maybe i'd have like
higher utility over time like i'm on the
beach kind of yeah half the time it'd
definitely be less rewarding so again
coming back to this like maybe it's
better than the natto kind of
self-interest but yeah in terms of this
all things considered like what's the
warding like yeah but then also just
loads of people you know that within
effective optimism there's a big
spectrum of people
there are some people who are just like
i'm in this all the time i'm just like
so absorbed i'm finding it so the
warning i'm just so committed to this
and then there's other people who are
like this is my job and i've got loads
of other interests too
and give it my all um just as i would
like any other job but then
evenings weekends holidays i just like
have a great time yeah and that's like a
very valid
and great way to live too yeah sure and
i guess it's very it's it's again too
easy to say that like oh but if i think
of the extreme scenario i wouldn't want
to spend all my time thinking about
these good causes therefore i'm going to
spend none of my time thinking of the
good causes because it's too hard to
think about exactly so we talked about
80 000 hours oh one one question on that
front eighty thousand hours have
recently been on a bit of a a sponsoring
spree sponsoring the tim ferriss show
which is which you've been on like ages
ago i i heard your episode on like 2015
or something
yeah it was years and years ago yeah
i'll be on again later this year nice
but you know his podcast is famously
expensive they've actually reached out
to sponsor my youtube channel as well so
they're sponsoring a video how does i
think i know the answer is like why why
does an organization that is just like
purely non-profit and free materials and
everything paying thousands if not tens
of thousands if not maybe hundreds to
temporaries and stuff for two
sponsor podcasts and things yeah i mean
essentially you can think of it as like
an investment so if you look at the
history of outreach that 80 000 hours
has done on like you know what for most
of the time is like an incredibly small
budget yeah the return like altruistic
return like how much impact you're
having with the money you've put in
is
extremely high yep so it's simplest so
there's many career paths we recommend
most people who follow 80 000 hours
advice are going to do dialect work yeah
but some choose this path called earning
to give where they deliberately earn
take a larger salary and you know
deliberately try and pursue a career
where they can earn a lot in order to
donate most of their wealth away
so let's even just put to aside the
large majority of the impact which is
why i direct paths just look at the
earning to give 80 000 hours has been
spent i don't know exactly the future
but some numbers of millions it's over
10 but not that much more than that tens
of millions on out of each
and there's a big lag in terms of when
we have the impact because we're talking
to people that yeah while they're still
at university most of the time
but let's just take one example of
impact which was in 2012 i was giving
these talks about learning to give one
of the talks was at mit there was an
audience member there who was called sam
and he was like oh these ideas make
sense yeah he went to a and to give and
quantitative fading it changed the and
then moved on to set his own up his own
company i believe he's now the richest
person in the world under the age of 35
has already given um hundreds of
millions of dollars through his
foundation this year and has publicly
said he will give away you know
essentially all of his wealth like 99 of
his wealth
and so
ignore all of the impact that we had
yeah apart from that one example of kind
of earning to give yeah well the roi
the amount of money we've raised for
good causes by doing that yeah you know
it's like 10 to 100 to one yeah now add
in all the other impact as well which is
like greater than that
you just yeah by doing this sort of
outreach talking to people especially
because no one's paying attention to
young people even though they have i
mean goldman sachses and mckinsey is and
they spend like a million dollars
per university um per year oh wow on
this sort of yeah that's about right at
least in the us
it's maybe a little lower in the uk
because you know for them getting like
really bright students to work for them
is worth an awful lot more than that
yeah for us like altruistically
considered we should be willing to pay
even more yeah because we're not just
getting people for a few numbers of
years we're steering people for the
entire course yeah it's like the ltv the
lifetime value exactly a convert to ea
is or to oh yeah just some someone who
yeah takes their career seriously in
terms of the good they have in the world
exactly so someone who was just gonna
they were gonna go do the investment
banking yeah not really having an
optimistic life someone who switches to
like okay i'm really gonna try and do
good yeah i'm gonna do that over the
course of my life yeah that's worth
millions of dollars
and so if we're doing you know we're
just experimenting with
i mean perhaps you know no one cares
about what you say about victim
authorities and we'll find out yeah but
uh probably i think that otherwise going
to be pretty good yeah it means we're
just like investing compared to the
value that we're creating like very
small amounts of money actually yeah and
if it is the case that we're generating
various significantly more resources for
good outcomes it's not just a nice thing
to do like we have a model obligation to
do it because otherwise just less good
is going to get done yeah i want to talk
about giving what we can and then can we
talk about long-termism absolutely
giving what we can what is what's
what's the deal there right so given
what we can launched in 2009 it's a
pledge for people to give at least 10
percent of their income to whatever
causes they believe will do the most to
positively impact the world so it's not
limited by cause area and you know we
recommend charities the effect health
and movement give well in particular
that commands global health and
development charities effective altruism
funds has a set of locations where you
can give but it's up to you the only
requirement is that you honestly believe
this is the best way of improving the
world yep
it started off with 23 people who had
pledged to give at least 10 yeah oh i
should say if you're a student we you
know you're not on an income as defined
in the pledge but we kind of ask people
to give one percent of whatever they're
living on yeah and then once you start
taking a salary the ten percent kicks in
yeah so we started off with 23 people it
was a small thing now we've grown as
over 7 000 people have taken the pledge
amounting to low number of billions of
dollars in pledge donations there's a
vibrant community that kind of overlaps
heavily with the effect wider effective
altruism community yeah and
yeah lots of people just feel like
whatever career path you know perhaps
again does not let the best be the enemy
of the good yeah i think look i want to
pursue the career i want to do
i'm not one of those like all in people
yeah but here's a way in which just
anyone can have an enormous impact yeah
and that's by giving 10 of your income
to the most effective causes i guess we
we sort of alluded to this in passing
but for people who aren't familiar like
what does that look like in terms of
impact like how how much money do you
need to give away to have what sort of
impact if you're donating to effective
charities the baseline is about five
thousand dollars will on average save a
life of a child in extreme poverty
that's if you fund something like
against malaria foundation or other
organizations working on
malaria now normally when you hear these
numbers they're kind of overlapped so i
used to work as a charity fundraiser and
i would say these absurd things like oh
it cost 20 pence to provide a dose of
polio that could save your life yeah um
this in contrast is like really it's our
best guess this is from enormous amounts
of research that's been done by givewell
it costs you know a few dollars to buy a
bed net that protects two children for
two years against malaria provide
protect enough children after five
thousand dollars worth of expenditure
you'll save a life yeah so that's one of
the things you can do that's kind of
among the most promising things in terms
of direct impact in global health and
development other things you could do
within climate change something like
averting one ton of carbon dioxide
equivalent best guess costs something
like a ton a dollar per ton again that's
really pretty good if you think that
in the uk you're not you and i we emit
about seven tons per year well we
probably admit more because i suspect we
travel more could see more but you know
around 10 tons of co2 per year well
entirely offsetting that
would cost 10 10 but there's no reason
why you should own the offset instead
you could still go much much further
than that then on some of the other
things we'll talk about some of the
long-term stuff it just becomes much
harder to
ascertain kind of quantitatively how
much you know you have to get into much
more speculative kind of calculations
right just in the nature of the thing
but i think it's plausible to me that
you can do even more good again and this
ten percent number where does that where
does the temperature number come from
why not five or fifteen or twenty a mix
of things so it's obviously there's some
amount of arbitrariness there it's not a
coincidence that we have 10 fingers we
can't attend there's this long tradition
of tithing where people for thousands of
years people much poorer than us we're
giving 10 but there's also an important
issue when we were kind of designing the
pledge of getting the balancing act like
where
if we had been promoting a one percent
pledge you might think oh you'd have
gotten so many more people so you'd have
done more good i think that would have
been a mistake because what we care
about is like how big a difference are
we making compared to how much people
are donating anyway yep in the uk the
average donation is about point seven
percent of income yeah per year and the
us is about two percent
and so
if we were taking that average person
we'd only be getting point three percent
of difference yep in fact the sort of
person to take the pledge is probably
already donating
you're doing no good at all yeah so 10
is large enough that people aren't
otherwise doing it
it's like okay this is you're really
kind of moving money that wouldn't have
otherwise happened yep toby initially
had the thought that giving what we can
would be about people who are capping
their income and giving
above that but the thought is that there
you've gone too far and there's just
gonna be so few people doing it that
people aren't gonna really get on board
yeah and so
this is like 10 is this like not like
you know slightly non-arbitrary number
yeah that's kind of in between these two
ways of failing yeah and again i get i
guess the the question i was always come
to is if i if i were to
think about this before if i would have
heard this idea before i initially
got and kind of drank the kool-aid and
realized that this is a good thing i
took the pledge i would have thought oh
but ten percent a lot of money like you
know my mom if she took a ten percent
hit her salary she we you know fairly
somewhat middle class family et cetera
et cetera
but you know money is one of those
things it's like it'll always be nice to
have a little bit more and like 10 you
know you say to parents they'd be like
oh gosh you know i couldn't possibly do
that because kids private school or
whatever
how do you
think about that
i think there's a couple of things to
think about there so
one thing is just imagine so people
normally make more money at least in the
beginning parts of the career make more
money over time
and you could imagine just oh i took
this one job that was like
made 10 less yeah like so than this
other job that's often kind of decisions
that people make and they often do that
because it's like oh it's going to be a
more satisfying job yeah people are
rarely like oh i've only had taken that
job
it's normally a small consideration
compared to other things
and often in fact if you're worried
about you mentioned your mom saying a 10
hit would feel really big yeah people
tend to get used to the amount of money
they have yeah and so one thing you can
do is like early on you say okay well
this would have been my earnings
trajectory yeah instead i'm never going
to go backwards i'm never going to live
have a year away i'm living on less than
i did before but the amount by which it
increases is going to increase a little
bit less than it would have otherwise
done yep such that i can scale up to ten
percent and then have that as a
sustainable amount yeah so there's kind
of one response is like
don't get yourself into the position
where you've already you're not used to
it so much that financial commitments
and then the second thought is thinking
about this in terms of global
distribution of income i actually i
don't know how much you earn my best
guess is that you're in the richest one
percent of the world's population by
income even after my pledge so i'm
taking that as my income i'm in the
richest five percent of the world's
population and there's a kind of thought
of like oh boohoo me like oh it's so
hard hardship like i'm still richer than
95 percent of people in the world yeah
like what's going on there yeah that
can't be like like 95 you know
let's even like drop off the bottom you
know fifty percent of people there's
forty five percent of people who are in
the richest half like yeah
if they're have like able to live their
lives then like why am i not able to so
that was very yeah that was something
that really moved me to begin with it's
like
i think people just do not appreciate
the sheer scale of global inequality
yeah and how much
even if you're just like
on a kind of middle class income in a
rich country you by glo like you know
you're part of the global elite yeah
because which currencies are just so
much wealthier than other countries yeah
nice this thing is you know peop people
just don't appreciate the scale of of
this or like
certainly for me like i i don't think i
have seen any of the documentaries about
like why meat is bad or poverty or or
anything like that other than if it
happened to be on tv and i haven't been
flicking through the channels but this
is a thing that i
want to do
to get more of that that thing that you
describe of like having genuinely having
that feeling of like oh [ __ ] these are
actual problems that you know we need to
solve fairly urgently
what would be like your i guess
recommended reading watching list for
someone like me who is like i've drawn
kool-aid i just don't feel anything and
i want i want to feel a little bit more
such a good question i mean i have found
and many people this is still more on
the intellectual side but i have found
the writings of peter singer enormously
influential so we've got a bunch of his
books in the flat some side copies as
well
so i should actually read those okay so
peter on the animal side animal
liberation yeah and he's redoing it um
there'll be another edition but maybe
out next year feminism morality was his
original article okay i still find it
very powerful yeah the life you can save
it was his follow-up my own good book
doing good better that's kind of less
again on the feeling side but more just
you know making the upbeat positive case
yep on
again on the kind of you mentioned me
the animal side of things speciesism the
documentary has
been yeah kind of related very highly
there's also kind of undercover
investigations which is basically
investigative journalists that go into
factory farms and just record what
happens there where there's an enormous
amount of brutality i mean yeah it's
this bizarre thing where if you ask
people like what do you think about
animal cruelty they'll be like i hate
animal cruelty it's disgusting yet
within these enormous silos hidden from
the rest of the world
just
animal cruelty like on an unimaginable
scale is happening within factory farms
and that's the meat we consume so that
yeah these undercover documentaries can
be incredibly powerful as well i
remember watching them again many years
ago
i like the idea of
kind of getting into philosophy yeah in
the sense that when i have these sorts
of conversations i feel super energized
by them i love hypothetical thought
experiments i often have conversations
with lucia about this a lot and when i
whenever i read a blog post by a
philosopher i'm always like whoa that's
so interesting
and i started listening to a podcast
called a history of philosophy without
any gaps okay which sort of traces what
the pre-socratic and then socratic and
like all of that kind of stuff happened
but it's a bit long and it's a bit dense
uh what is how how do i get like a kind
of dummies
the idea of
what the field of philosophy is about so
that then i can
and maybe this isn't necessarily
prerequisite so that i can then dive
into someone like peter singer and
understand the con the context behind
how he came up okay so the single best
podcast
if for the dummies guide for sure would
be philosophy bytes which has been
running for years and years like way
before podcasts were cool yeah that's
just they're very short introductions
and some of these to particular ideas
okay for something that's like more
in-depth and occasionally
i mean it's kind of remarkable that this
is on the radio but in our time by mel
with melvin bragg okay uh it's a radio 4
program but it's exceptionally everyday
and they get like really top academics
on the show and have like quite an
intense intellectual conversation it's
very wide arranging in our time covers
history science and philosophy yeah but
you can
on the podcast apps they separate it out
if you want so you can just listen to
the philosophy side of things sick um if
you want something fun very bad wizards
okay so pretty fun the philosophy
podcast
yeah i think those would be my top
recommendations perfect but then if i
were you i would just get people on the
show and you just start grilling them
like okay um then it's a win-win i think
yeah i could make it a bunch of
recommendations yeah fun for us oh that
would be amazing that would be very very
handy yeah because i love the idea of
being like i i think one of the glorious
things about having built this platform
be able to have someone like you the
podcast
of
let's
try and do the most good with our time
and with our money
caveat i pro while having a nice
standard of life ourselves but there's
no reason why those two things
necessarily have to be in conflict which
is why i've taken the 10 pledge for
giving what we can and why i give ten
percent of my income to charity every
year and one thing we were thinking
about a lot as well is in a way like for
us where uh the point of our i guess
business and the thing that i really
care about is helping people live their
best life and i think there's sort of
five pillars there of health wealth love
happiness and impact
and i think on the impact front if we
could for example
get more people into
ea yeah i i went on 80 000 hours i did
that little survey of like i'm booking
one one like what are all the causes you
care about yeah obviously of the 50 of
them the only one i cared about was
getting more people to care about this
stuff but i'm hoping after watching and
reading more of peter singers that i
will actually start to
physically care about more
more of these understand that yeah but
so i think i think we can have some
level of public health or public good
impact through just inc and encouraging
more people to join this stuff and so
that's like my current level of
knowledge with
and and i guess if i'm thinking of what
a good cause is i would go and give well
and i would see against malaria
foundation i would donate to lucia's
charity leap by the way which are hiring
we've been told to plug down below if
you would like to work for a high impact
nonprofit talk about it what we owe the
future thank you for the yeah signing no
worries we are the future the the future
the future starts with you what's the
deal with long-termism cool so
the core idea is just
let's just zoom out for the moment so
we're normally concerned by the problems
that affecting us today or like the
current election cycle
but let's take just a much larger
perspective on our history and our
future so you know universe started 13
and a half billion years ago first
replicators about four billion years ago
of applicators oh like first of all
the first life yeah cool on our first
animals about 600 million years ago homo
sapiens about 300 000 years ago
agriculture about 10 000 years ago
industrial revolution kind of 250 years
ago and now we are here now yes what's
going on
okay so that's the past
spans an enormous amount of time yeah
what about the future
well how long could the human species
last for
we've had about 300 000 years in our
past
a typical mammal species lasts for about
a million years so if so if we lasted as
long as a typical mammal species we
might
live another seven hundred thousand
years yep that's big already that's a
long time yeah but things get even
bigger yeah we're not a typical mammal
species in any way we have a hundred
times the biomass of any um animal
that's ever walked the earth we
you know have technology that kind of
means two things one it means
we could end
so we could end the lifespan of our
species much earlier we could entirely
wipe ourselves out and we'll talk about
that in a second or we could live much
longer again so if we succeeded
extending our lifespan past the typical
mammal species well there could be
hundreds of millions
of uh years left while the earth is
still habitable the lifespan of the sun
is something like five to eight billion
years
if we were able to ultimately take to
the stars that would be hundreds of
trillions of years before the last
conventional stars star formations okay
so when we look to the future and the
potential scale of civilization
it's truly immense yeah
and why does this matter well it matters
because future people matter if i could
think about
you know harms and benefits that could
be
you know
i could prevent or bestow on people
alive today
and then i think oh i could also
cause harms and benefits to people
hundreds or a thousand years time yeah
it just the distance in time just
doesn't really seem to matter in the
same way the distance in space doesn't
matter so what do you mean by it doesn't
matter well suppose i tell you you can
prevent a genocide a million people will
die
and now i say oh but it'll happen in 100
years time or it'll happen in a thousand
years time or 2000 years time but the
same number of people for sure and let's
just assume for sure we'll be saved
either way yep are you like oh well 2000
years doesn't matter who cares about
that like i don't think so
i think it's like a matter of common
sense
the mere fact that someone
will exist at a later date and time yes
doesn't change their moral status they
have just the same level of model worth
okay yep fine
we can dig into that if you want yes
let's do that
surely there's a discount function here
well what are we discounting for so it
could be that you're more unsure
about okay impacts that you have later
in the future but i guess in this
lecture
i was certain to be able to prevent a
genocide now versus in a year's time
yeah i'd obviously be like well
i mean both
yeah i'd like to prevent both exactly
but if you told me i could only prevent
a genocide in a year's time i'd be
thinking all right let's
get everything into gear and figure out
how to prevent this genocide for sure
yeah so i think like uncertainty can of
course be the reason why like some
future impacts if it is therefore more
uncertain okay there's a reason to
ignore that okay but bear in mind yeah
all of these future people they have
lives they're just people like you and
me they have hopes and themes like we
can interact with them yeah you know if
i like
take you know it's other aspects of
common sense like people worry about
radioactive waste
that you know it pollutes for thousands
of years
even hundreds of thousands of years or
carbon dioxide that we emit into the
atmosphere
that will persist a significant fraction
of that persists for like a hundred
thousand years it's only after that time
that it all gets sucked out of the
atmosphere and the geophysical impacts
last that long as well okay and again
should we just be ignoring that it's
like oh it's a future time
whatever it seems like yeah no there's
something about that that feels weird to
be completely ignoring
impact because it's like
you know obviously i care about the
world that my kids live in yeah and
their kids because and probably their
kids too yeah
and that's where my own personal feeling
would probably stop but like
obviously morally speaking and and yeah
morally speaking i should really care
about everyone else yeah not just like
yeah and i said look they're equally as
important there might well be some
you know genuine reasons you have to
care more about people alive today so
you mentioned your kids like they're the
people who are alive today you have
these special relationships with yeah
like with your brother and so on and
that can give extra reasons yeah or they
might reciprocity so reasons to you know
people who've benefited you that you can
you know benefit them as well so some
there are some additional reasons for
caring more about the present okay but
again like genocide cases yeah we should
care somewhat about yeah i'm okay i
fully buy that i should prevent a
genocide whether it happens in a 10
years 100 years or a thousand years okay
fantastic okay and then you combine that
with just the sheer scale
of what's at stake where i was telling
you this zoomed out view of just how
large a future we could potentially have
and if we should care about future
people well
even on the most conservative of these
estimates future people outnumber this
like a thousand to one yeah so
there have been 100 billion people in
the past about 8 billion people live
today yeah something like a thousand
trillion people to come on more
on these more kind of
ambitious or optimistic um accounts but
which i think we should take seriously
then that number gets larger again
trillions of or trillions of people yeah
outnumbering the pleasant okay so the
stakes are just huge yeah enormous
imagine if we found a society that had
like a trillion people trillions billion
people alive today
and you know it was perhaps under the
sea or something and otherwise
inaccessible had currently been
inaccessible to us yeah we think oh my
god how are we impacting them this is
huge yeah
and then the third idea is that we
really can make a difference
not just to the present day but actually
to the entire course of future
civilization
and i think that's because of
you know i gave you this long history
but we are at a time of exceptionally
rapid and unusually rapid change
compared to either the past so it's only
been 250 years since the industrial
revolution when the scale of kind of
technological innovation massively
increased
and we also i think there are good
reasons for thinking that can't continue
indefinitely maybe it can continue for
hundreds of years maybe one or two
thousand years but not even tens of
thousands of years let alone the
millions of years that might continue
into the future
and because we're so rapidly advancing
through new technology that creates kind
of risks and opportunities that i think
actually do shape the entire course of
the future the clearest are risks of
extinction so nuclear weapons were had
unprecedented both the atomic bomb and
then you know the atomic bomb had about
a thousand times the destructive power
of conventional weapons the hydrogen
bomb had about a thousand times greater
conventional power greater destructive
power than the atomic weapons
that's just like the beginning of like a
new era of destructive power yeah um i
think most scary of all is engineered
pandemics engineered pathogens okay so
pandemics in the past have
already been among have caused the
largest death tolls of all catastrophes
of all time okay so the black death
killed about 10 of the world's
population precise figures are uncertain
covid is utter colossal tragedy in terms
of global i think killed about 0.2
percent of the world's population so far
which
on the scale of the kind of catastrophes
we've had is actually competitively
small of yes there's been many pandemics
that have killed kind of upwards of one
percent of the world's population
but then when we look to the future
pandemics could get much worse again if
they're with viruses that have been
deliberately engineered to be
destructive so you could imagine a virus
that has the fatality light of ebola the
infectiousness of measles well now
you've got something that like
especially if um deliberately targeted
to do so could kill a very large
proportion of the world's population
maybe even and then in the worst case
scenario it was literally everyone and
now how long does that effect last
well if the human race goes extinct
we're not coming back from that
that really is an event that could
happen that would have an impact over
this entire course of the future yeah
and we've already said this feature is
huge future people matter
there's this enormous amount at stake
and so
that's kind of one way in which there
could be an event that could persist
indefinitely extinction or otherwise end
of civilization
the second way is i call kind of value
lock-in okay sorry can i just ask a
question on that absolutely yeah yeah
there's lots there's been lots there
yeah okay so this is all very scary one
somewhat weird question is something
i've heard on on a youtube video in one
of these stephen crowder's chair changed
my mind about abortion yeah is that
one
argument for
life begins at conception life begins
begins before then life begins at like
sperm itself yeah is that every time you
masturbate you're committing mass
genocide yeah or something like that
now if that's an argument against
um the idea that
every sperm is sacred presumably yes
yeah exactly because that would just be
absurd yep now
if we are saying that for example being
able to so
future lives matter what is the
difference between that and saying
basically sperm matter and that those
future lives have not been realized just
yet there's a difference between you
know the people who think that
even sperm have like moral status are
persons right and then you're well i
think there's two things and then you're
saying you're killing them that's you
know very different from saying like
there will be people in the future
who are fully grown persons there will
be others and it can be harmed or
benefited okay and if if there is an
extinction event then it means that
those people are prevented from being
born
yes so there's two ways okay in which we
can impact the very long-term future
it's like extinction and
that
is an enormous strategy so far that
kills everyone yeah like that's
extremely bad yes but then it has the
second effect of preventing the
existence of future lives yeah and there
we can get into some of the intense
model philosophy which i now know you're
going to love
uh about just how should we think about
that loss okay and i devote kind of two
chapters of the book just to that
question because yeah you really do need
to get into some other model philosophy
to think about that but then there's a
second way of positive of impacting the
long-term future which is just changing
the value of the future in those worlds
where we do survive so i kind of think
about it like extending humanity's
lifespan versus increasing its quality
of life
and i think in particular there are
scenarios that again could occur
essentially where society gets locked
into a particular state with a
particular ideology governing a
particular set of values that could
persist forever and in particular i
think that the date the point of time at
which
we have um sufficiently advanced
artificial intelligence that
ais can act as agents themselves
could be this point of lock-in in the
kind of extreme you can imagine this
kind of global totalitarian ai enabled
state
i think there's it that is really
something that could persist
indefinitely not just an extremely long
time but maybe forever yeah and again we
can go into that too and so those are
the kind of two things that two pathways
by which
events could occur in a lifetime that i
think really do have these extremely
long-lasting impacts okay so
two main reasons number one is something
bad could happen in our lifetime that
would cause the extinction of the human
race for example engineers pandemics or
like nuclear war yeah very very very
worst case nuclear war yeah or
okay so those those sorts of things or
like an asteroid hitting the earth and
us not
not like killing it before it gets here
yep and secondly it's like okay
let's say that even if we don't extinct
our entire species
there are all these people who will who
will come after us our kids our
grandkids and so on yep at infinitum for
potentially trillions of years and if we
screw up the world in a in such a way i
guess physically
but also like governmentally in terms of
how society is structured yeah or like
ideologically in terms of like what
people think is good and bad yeah that
actually has enormous impact on the
quality of the life of these people in
the future exactly if we value the
quality of life of people now like we do
with quality adjusted life years
and the fact that we are keen on
preventing
illnesses that might not kill someone
but might yeah debilitate their quality
of life we should also have that same at
least something close to that same level
of moral
uh caringness to use that word about
people in the future exactly so you can
imagine a future that's like wonderful
blissful it's like everyone is free they
can do their own things they're we've
like figured out the laws of nature
we've got incredible technology and
model progress and
everyone has these like long healthy
happy lives can pursue whatever they
want could also imagine a future that's
almost you know all the power in society
is held by a single dictator and the
entire rest of society are essentially
the slaves yeah i think that
developments over even the course of
this century could be crucial to
determining kind of which of those
civilizations we get and that's a like
completely scary thought and for that
thinking that the former is better than
the latter you don't need to get into
the
kind of moral philoso intense moral
philosophy about whether loss of future
life is like how bad yeah it's just kind
of obvious we'd rather have a world
where people are
okay exactly okay great what comes next
i guess okay and then if we accept all
those as like yes so then if we accept
all those the question is just okay what
should we do yeah and there are some
standard examples so again extinction's
some
the easiest thing to focus on we are
doing enormous amounts of work to ensure
that we prevent the next pandemic and in
particular prevent worst case pandemics
if you're particular yeah some of the
things you can do one thing i'm pretty
excited about is far ultraviolet
radiation
so basically just
intense like far ultraviolets but
certain spectrum of light yeah
sterilizes microbes so you could put it
just like in light sockets yeah and it
would just sterilize all of the microbes
yeah at least very recent development
that's cool probably we're going to fund
it quite a lot yeah it seems like it
would be very good indeed yeah it's also
something that could just be very
universally applicable because here's
the kind of worthy with feature
pandemics is
you create a vaccine against flu but it
doesn't work against other sorts of
pathogens or some sort of drug it works
against some pathogens
if we're really worried about the class
of pandemics as a whole including very
worst pandemics including things that
people are designing potentially for the
destructive power yes as part of a wet
biological weapons program or something
you really need very general purpose
technology yes this is something that
could be very general purpose okay and
theoretically someone
i suppose theory theoretically someone
could design the virus that is
has a protein that shields it against
far ultraviolet potentially but i think
these like mechanical ways of describing
physical mechanisms for destroying um
pathogens or protecting against
pathogens and at least they're much more
general and much more robust than like
exactly targeted a vaccine even like a
broad spectrum vaccine
so kind of yeah this would be one
another is fairly advanced ppe so oh
okay personal detective degree i was
like wait what oh yeah
yeah well i mean i am also people doing
more philosophy um maybe not so helpful
on the pandemic side of things um
advanced like personal protective
equipment exactly yeah so again if you
can imagine we've got like masks or
intense personal protective gear that is
just so good that like no viruses can
kind of pass through it perhaps you've
got like kind of nano materials that you
can breathe through but viral particles
can't pass through again very very broad
protection yeah so that's kind of on the
technology side those things we can do
and then on the policy side we can just
start to
have people just taking pandemics like a
lot more seriously so
there was this bill that was you know we
just had like
the worst pandemic in a hundred years
you really think that society would be
like
this was bad we're gonna stop this again
yeah
it cost you know tens of trillions of
dollars as well as tens of millions of
lives there was this bill that was being
proposed that we were really kind of
pushing for to be accepted for like
about 70 billion dollars in the u.s to
say like never again
and what happened
you didn't get by partisan support
no one was really there to champion it
in the u.s government and so it got
whittled down and whittled down is now
maybe two or three billion dollars but
there's not like appetite organically
for saying no we want we want to have
the policy in place to say never again
to pandemics right even though there are
things we can do so i mean a very simple
thing is just
constant detection so
you're just
in
a hundred locations around the world or
maybe more you're just you know going
through wastewater for example yeah and
just scanning for like is there
something we don't know
in this and like as soon as it is you
can like maybe get on top of things like
much faster than otherwise that's
something we don't do we could easily do
it it would be an ongoing thing it would
protect us dramatically against like
future pandemics because you'd be able
to potentially contain things much
faster and there's you know there's more
there too how worried are you about
how worried should we be about genus
about like engineered viruses and stuff
i mean i think extremely worried i mean
i think it's i mean it's already the
case that we can genetically engineer
viruses so gain and function research is
very common and this is done in order to
protect against future viruses so you're
worried perhaps about how might the flu
evolve so that it becomes more
transmissible or more deadly
and so yeah you take a virus change its
dna it becomes more sensitive
transmissible then you can study it yep
so we can already do this to some extent
technology is just getting better and
better this is actually an area of the
world where we're familiar with kind of
moore's law like computing's very fast
moving area of technology moore's law is
like cost
for a given amount of computation halves
every 18 months for sequencing dna in
mary areas it's like faster than that
it's actually like extremely fast-moving
area of technology so i think it's just
utterly we already can do this to some
extent the ability to do this very well
i think very predictably is some
technology we will have
even within a decade or two secondly so
and that means you've got the ability to
design very dangerous pathogens so
the genetic recipe for smallpox it's
online like you can just download it oh
okay yeah that's like people are not at
the moment very like sufficiently
concerned about the sorts of information
we're putting out there okay especially
given kind of future tech yeah but again
we could make things that are much worse
than smallpox potentially
and then here's the and you might think
well no one really wants to do this
however just if you look at biological
weapons programs in the past
even though it doesn't seem to make
sense to design biological weapons
because like how do you protect yourself
like yeah if you're infecting the others
um other side they're not isn't it going
to come back to you
well the ussr had 60 000 people at his
height really trying to design like some
of the worst case like some of the most
deadly viruses um they could and produce
them on mass so that it could be used in
war yeah you can imagine it being like a
kind of a deterrence so perhaps it's a
country that doesn't have nuclear
weapons yeah but they say like look if
you nuke us then we're going to just let
this pathogen go and then just
everyone's gone yeah that can be quite
scary yup then the second aspect is that
in terms of something with destructive
power
in some ways we got lucky with nuclear
weapons where fissile material is very
easy to contain and it's easy to monitor
because it's just so hard to make facile
material yeah usually
it's like comparatively easy to identify
a country that is trying to do that yeah
in contrast like there are already these
like at-home like build your own dna
kits
small amounts of dna like
the cost to do this is only going to get
cheaper over time
that means like by default
on the default directory if we don't
intervene yes well the number of actors
who would have the capa that would have
the kind of cost and ability to start
playing around with such deadly um okay
viruses so because technology is
improving so ridiculously fast at some
point in the very near future i could
theoretically go on smallpox recipe.org
download the recipe and be able to
manufacture the smallpox virus using a
male home order exactly at least if if
we don't get our back together in terms
of the policy and regulatory and i know
that i'm a decent person but like
you know exactly and most people are and
this is the thing that like mostly
assures me is like
how many people in the world really want
to destroy the whole world
it's not that many it's like there's a
lot
it's also not zero exactly okay and so
when i look over the course of
essentially like yeah what's the risk i
put from extinction via engineered
pathogens and i'm like somewhere between
point one and one percent maybe i'm like
point five percent or something other
people i know who are experts in the
area particularly and about one percent
toby ordon his book puts it at three
percent but here's the thought like if
you were getting on a plane and they
said hey only a one in a thousand chance
that this plane is going to crash and
kill everyone on board it's not like
you're particularly assured by that and
we take enormous amounts of effort to
stop playing crashes which have much
lower
risks of catastrophe than this
but yet with the all of society we are
not paying attention to that because
it's like
you know it's not yet on people's minds
and even with a pandemic that killed 10
million people cost trillions of tens of
trillions of dollars
nonetheless people are still not paying
attention to like actually how bad could
it get yeah we need to be really careful
with what we're creating the bloody hell
yeah
okay so that's engineered viruses and
bio weapons and stuff which we should be
sure should try and intervene with so so
other than these sort of broad spectrum
uv thingy bulbs or nano fiber
ppe
what other things can we do
can we do so stop the cat from getting
out the bag as it were yeah so again
then there's also on the policy side so
i said there could be like constant
monitoring i think that's going to be
really important another thing is just
like in terms of like scientific culture
and policy just like choosing what we
do and don't like the sort of science we
do and don't engage in yeah
where you know there are certain areas
of science there are certain things we
don't do scientifically on ethical
grounds yeah we don't experiment on
humans for example we don't expect
humans for example if we wanted to clone
a human like we could that is a
technology like you know maybe it would
cost a certain amount of money but like
it's within the within reach we've
cloned monkey
monkeys all sorts of things we don't do
and have delayed that by like many
decades we could do the same with this
so we could say look we're not like
we're just not going to engage in
research that is differentially
advancing
this kind of very dangerous technology
instead we're just going to focus on
research efforts and the things that are
you know provide because and importantly
like a lot of this these are really well
motivated scientists they're wanting to
help people there is genuine like
benefit here as well it's just that
there's enormous like risks
and so instead we can just focus on we
can say like look this isn't the sort of
thing we're going to pursue instead
we're going to focus on research that
just more genuinely beneficial so one
way you could do this is just introduce
third-party liability insurance so what
do you mean in just the same way like
when you have a car yeah you have to
take out third party insurance so that
if you hit someone you have to the cost
is on you yeah in the same way if there
was a lab yeah and the virus escapes i
mean this only helps with like private
work not government weapons programs but
if you have a lab and the lab escapes
yeah and i should say lab escapes are
extremely common oh okay uh yeah this is
again like under-reported but we can go
into the history of lab leaks it's like
pretty disliking it's pretty shocking
okay but yeah if it if it leaks and
escapes from the lab then you the la you
the laboratory are kind of on the hook
for those costs okay um i think if you
introduced that all of the most
dangerous and it was global
all of the most dangerous research would
kind of disappear overnight because
even though that's a cost that they are
imposing on society yeah without other
people
accepting that cost it is not being
currently born entirely like yeah the
labs are worthy about their staff
getting infected but not about the world
the world getting infected but what
about like
insert government x or y or z that will
not buy into to a mass agreement that
hey let's not do this research on
biological weapons you can imagine
insert government x being like hey the
whole world's not researching these
weapons let's do it in secret it's tough
so it means they don't think we're going
to get a perfect solution unless
the governments that were bought in were
also willing to exert significant
political pressure but yeah considered a
vogue state like north korea there's a
limit to what you can do i mean if china
were on board with this then perhaps
they can exert sufficient political
pressure that they could get on board as
well yeah but you could at least slow
things down you know north korea is not
the technological leader in the world
and so yeah if the major technological
leaders were willing to say look we're
gonna just we're gonna really put this
on ice until our defensive biological
capabilities are very strong okay i
think the world would be in a better
better place how did this happen for
nuclear weapons and what are the what
are your concerns about nuclear weapons
in the future when you say how did this
happen and then how did we put the cat
back in the bag i mean or have we
i mean we didn't really so nuclear
weapons first developed by the us at the
end of the second world war that was in
1945 and they were used
immediately upon development
four years later the ussr had the first
nuclear weapons
and then um not so long after that other
nuclear countries yeah the us uk sorry
as well as the uk france aina india
pakistan some others
and there was
there have been some major successes
successes the peak of the use of nuclear
weapons was of the arsenals of nuclear
weapons was in the late in the 80s i
think okay it peaked at about 40 000
warheads now there's only about
9 000 warheads right that's almost
entirely between the us and ussr right
so they were all like they were sort of
competing to see who could have the
biggest arsenal exactly in case of
in case of no like nuclear war exactly
then just kind of long slow periods of
diplomacy were able to get those kind of
numbers down um i really don't think
we'll ever see a point where it's at
zero yeah and then again because it was
very hard to develop kind of new nuclear
yeah
weapons there can be intense political
pressure especially from the very
powerful countries that you know we're
going back 60 years as u.s uk yes um
ussr they have sufficient power that
they can
ensure that other countries don't start
and so i guess if you're an individual
interested in a high impact career and
you get into diplomacy for example
you could have outsized influence
compared to if you did not decide you
wanted to go into that for example for
example yeah yeah for example like that
guy that stopped in the cuban missile
crisis uh yes the guy who didn't press
the button even though the communication
that that story that i heard somewhere
or other yeah so that's an enormous
impact on the world yeah this story was
um so cuban missile crisis
very close call for the us and ussr
going to war jfk put the figure out but
somewhere between one and three and one
and two the
nuclear war was the result there was a
particular submarine that it had lost
radio contact with the rest of the fleet
it was nuclear armed there
but ships on the surface
were trying to indicate to that
submarine that issued rise to the
surface by dropping kind of dummy depth
charges however the submarine had no
idea the leader of the submarine had no
idea what was happening
he thought war had broken out he he was
very angry
and he was like yeah we should launch
the protocol if i recall correctly was
that as long as kind of two out three of
the leadership said yes
it's like to launch the nuclear weapons
they should do so
it was a pure luck that there was a high
up a very high up official vastly
archipov who was war veteran himself an
actual war hero also happened to be on
there and he was like no we shouldn't
launch the nuclear weapons it's like too
risky we should go up to the surface
instead and he managed to win the
argument it was really like fluke that
he he shouldn't even like it was fluke
that he was on the subway yeah in the
first place right but yeah he
like in that case single-handedly
stopped all out nuclear war yeah that's
a very close call that we had
and so if you can be in a position of
such influence as wesley arkhipov was
that's an enormous way to have you know
that's an enormous impact that he has
and it does feel weird like as an
altoist oh you should go and work in
defense policy or something like that
it's not the standard path yeah
exactly
but if you're thinking about what are
things that are really consequential in
the world like what weapons are being
built when do people when do countries
go to war
how do they handle these like very like
tense and contingent moments
in terms of decisions to go to war well
those are just like that's just very
high impact and having kind of more
sensible better informed more altruistic
and
you know morally motivated people in the
room
just makes the world go better
because it wasn't just vaselia
as a story of a kind of close call and
many other examples as well where it
seems like individual actors just saying
no is actually what was the difference
between war and uh not war what's the
risk with nuclear weapons hydrogen bombs
etc
like now
in the future how worried are you i mean
i'm very worried
about the prospect of a nuclear war so
what's the chance that we have a nuclear
war
in our lifetimes like in all that
nuclear war
i'd say at least 20 percent uh really
yeah 20
yeah i mean we yeah historically
historically the lives of ourselves and
our parents are very is like very weird
because there's been such a long period
of peace right so we think of the second
world you know we think of the 20th
century it's like the most yeah all the
way deadly
ever and like
certainly world war one and two were
extreme events in terms of how deadly
they were
but war between great powers is like the
norm throughout all of history right
and so
the stranger thing is that we've had the
70 years of comparative peace
yeah and obviously it's not been a
peaceful time no almost numbers of wars
yeah but no war between kind of great
powers partly i think that's just luck
that the ussr and us never went to war
but then one argument for this is just
because the u.s has been such a hegemon
yeah so it's like
other than the possibility
it's like who are you going to mess with
exactly that will change over the course
of the century um china is i mean
depending on how you can already has
overtaken us as an economic power
certainly will in the future and will as
a military power too that could change
the kind of underlying dynamics
and so when we look at kind of
forecasting platforms like what's the
chance of a yeah what's the chance of
kind of world war three war between
great powers yeah over the course of the
next it looks to be something like
one in three one and two something
bloody hell and then yeah some discount
for like what's the chance that turns
into a yeah a kind of a nuclear war okay
yeah 20 would seem about like obviously
you can quibble but sure if it's ten
percent if it's forty percent yeah it
doesn't know where you're going
yeah so that's very scary i think that
would be extremely bad from a long-term
perspective not least you know it would
white europe and the us off the map i
think that like there are plausible
arguments that like liberal democracy is
actually like a quite fragile thing
we're quite lucky to be living in touch
that that's the kind of yeah so
widespread globally rather than without
authoritarian governments does this
further question of like would it kill
literally everybody i think that's very
unlikely the early kind of carl sagan
and others like early like anti-nuclear
advocates often you know sometimes make
claims like oh this would be the end
like little end of humanity everyone
would die i think that was seriously
overstated i mean you kind of don't need
to overstate it so already you're
talking about like hundreds of millions
of dead from the direct explosions if
there is a nuclear winter of some form
which i don't know i think significant
chance maybe like one in three that's
that occurs it's still like it's still
kind of unclear yeah like there hasn't
been that much modeling on it
surprisingly okay yeah but still
significant chance that's then billions
dead
nonetheless i think like unless things
change radically so you could imagine a
world where arsenals are like a thousand
times greater than they are now yeah
it's not
in terms of global gdp it's not that
expensive to create new nuclear warheads
or where there's like next level again
of kind of nuclear of kind of nuclear
power possibly that gets into kind of
extinction level territory but otherwise
i think like yeah people
some large number of people would
survive yeah but the kind of devastation
that would invoke in terms of the
shifting the trajectory of human
civilization and negative direction
would be absolutely huge i think yeah
okay so we've talked i'm sorry that
there's a conversation that we were so
light-hearted in the first half
yeah
so we've talked about engineered bio
weapons we've talked about nukes what
else are you worried about what else
should we at large be worried about yeah
so those are the things i'm most worried
about in terms of catastrophe just like
utter destruction on the world yep the
other side of things is like
it's a little bit harder to get clips
with but i think is as or maybe even
more important which is this idea of
value lock-in so
value-locking yeah so like or
ideological lock-in so the idea that you
know we have been making model progress
it was only a few hundred years ago like
1700 like three out of four people were
enforced labor some form of forced labor
and i talk about this at length in the
book it's kind of
uh we could go into it takes a while you
know i think that like near elimination
of slavery worldwide or like legal
abolition you know i think that was
plausibly at least a somewhat contingent
event like it was as a
as a result of like moral arguments and
moral campaigns what it was a contingent
event contingent in the sense like it
could have gone otherwise oh right so
could there be a world that had the same
level of technology that we have now but
where you know you and i like
rather than your employees you have
slaves kind of working for you and
that's just regarded as kind of morally
normal thing yeah like i'm not sure
maybe it was just like inevitable that
it was gonna um because it was like a
very like very morally normal thing for
absolutely ages for ages it was like i
mean it was really like at least by the
slaveholders uh i mean it was across all
societies so
almost every society
after the hunter-gatherer like
agriculture society had um some form of
slave holding and we listened to like
the stoics and stuff but they were chill
about slaves oh yeah yeah exactly yeah
all of the you know yeah all of the
philosophers and all the philosophies
they all translated they defended
slavery as well like at least accepted
it as part of life yeah you know these
were people that were dedicating their
lives to moral reflection plato and
aristotle yeah emmanuel kant one of the
great rational rationalists
enlightenment philosophers like defended
slavery even the kind of enlightenment
philosophers that are regarded as like
anti-slavery yeah it's very tepid right
like montesquieu is like oh yeah well
people shouldn't really be slaves unless
it's hot if there's a hot climate then
like yeah slavery is okay then it's like
so people it's really i think the thing
i kind of partly want to do in the book
is really
make people appreciate other people can
have very different moral points of view
yeah because right now for us i mean
just to go on the slavery example like
it's it's it's one of those things where
it's like
well what about slavery is like the
trump card in any kind of
argument you're having exactly because
it's always that it's just such a
no-brainer that obviously slavery
obviously
obviously it's so bad
it's basically axiomatic at this point
but like 300 years ago
if you and i had been born into
basically any other society yeah and
were part of the kind of the elites of
that society it would be rationalized
yeah exactly we'd be rationalizing it
probably we wouldn't even be talking
about it yeah because it's just such a
normal like kind of easy because yeah
exactly
exactly we wouldn't have been talking
about vegetarianism there's lots of
things and so i think it really could go
either way and then in the future i
think it could be that the world settles
and some kind of set of model values
that then just persist indefinitely and
yeah
okay as in so
um at the moment there's been like a lot
of model change especially at the moment
it's not it's not inevitable that could
continue and i think we've seen a lot of
moral progress in fact as well but we
could see the kind of untimely end of
model progress where that could happen
in a couple of ways one
if you end up just having like the
single world culture or world government
then it could be
that it could be that that's like not a
very morally explorer to the single
culture yeah or kind of one world
government and so you just have this one
ideology gets locked in forever
so this is kind of clearlist if you look
at you know totalitarian regimes that we
saw in the 20th century yeah so the
nazis they aimed for the thousand year
life they were aiming for you know at
least aspirationally yep control over
the world forever
with a single set of like with a single
ideology and part of the reason we see
model change over time is that we have
kind of competition moral competition
either across societies
yeah so why did the soviet union fall
kind of in part at least it's like you
know that there's these other countries
with like
liberal democracies and there's a better
life if you've not got that globally yes
then that's one reason for kind of moral
change
um yeah i think you can see other people
like on tv and stuff exactly oh they
they're free hang on that that's good
yeah exactly
or internally so we live in a liberal
society so people can pursue all sorts
of different smaller forms of life and
then you can say like oh hey actually
like for example you know there are
people in same-sex relationships and
actually that just seems better for them
and like over time like the better model
arguments can win out yeah but again if
you have this kind of totalitarian
regime you've got like givens to the
ideology you don't necessarily have that
yeah and that's that's the sort of thing
that will then reinforce itself exactly
and you get these sort of you know the
final empire like brandon sanderson type
situations where you have a government
ruling for a thousand years and you've
got these little
resistance rebels but like they can't
take on the light of the empire exactly
kind of vibes yeah exactly and again
like
you know we've had kind of in some sense
neo messes like yeah you know i don't
think that the nazis like ever had a
real chance of like
getting global governance but you could
imagine like it's not such a different
kind of way history could have gone such
that they could have really won out or
the ussr could have like really kind of
conquered the world
but then the most scary thing of all or
like the most worthy thing of all is
like future technology okay so one yeah
one other reason for like change over
time is just that people die and that
creates this kind of churn over time
that again is something that may change
this is now i mean one would be if we
just simply stop the like biological
aging process people would have natural
lifespans of like many thousands of
years but a second and i'll caveat like
this is where things start feeling like
the most sci-fi but okay i really want
to defend them as like not sci-fi
actually like things that could
completely happen in a lifetime yeah is
again once you start having ai systems
that are agents in the relevant sense
yeah so we have ai systems that are like
narrow at the moment they're very good
at playing go or like playing starcraft
or predicting or like writing text we
don't have things that realistic that
like can perform many different tasks in
the way that humans can but that will
like probably that will change yeah
and the good arguments for thinking
might change in our lifetime so in
particular
the latest machine learning models
the amount of computation they use it's
kind of comparable to like a honey bee
brain it's nothing isn't it yeah
but predictably so yeah all of that
stuff amazing stuff computers were doing
all like less than a b yeah predictably
though like it's very unclear like yeah
neuroscience neuroscientists
it's like very unclear like how much
computation the human brain does
but
we can give ranges it spans many orders
of magnitude
it's really very likely that
unless there's some other catastrophe
that preempts preempts this
that we will be creating ml machine
learning models ai models that
have the same amount of computational
power as the human plane and
again pretty likely by the end of the
century that we will have also done like
a compatible a compatible amount of like
training what yeah the search is called
training and so it really looks that
like within our lifetime
we're kind of within the developments of
ai yeah we're moving over the kind of
crucial boundary of like artificial
intelligence rivaling of exceeding human
intelligence it's plausible we're moving
to a world where yeah the kind of
smartest beings in the planet are
digital rather than human one set of
concerns there is like
well what if this the ai's like take
over disempower humans this is very
familiar now from nick bosh them super
intelligence and other discussion um i
talk about this in the book and i think
it's really important and like there's
like tons of good work on it and we can
talk about that
but even if we navigate that challenge
there's still this new thing of just
this creates a moment of lock-in
where one as soon as you've got um
artificially intelligent agents you now
have beings that are essentially
immortal because any piece of software
is infinitely replicable yeah any piece
of hardware will wear out but if you can
just copy and copy and paste the
software then
if you have
either like it's just like an ai
enforcing a constitution or kind of
sorry an ai enforcing a constitution uh
yeah so you could imagine that like so
let's suppose you're a kind of global
dictator yes i'm a global dictator yes
i've got aia achieve come on which
you've already wanted to do because yeah
it's been on the bucket list for a while
you have your ideology yes you're like
fervent zealot in the way that yes
hitler or stalin was you want that
ideology to persist forever yes what can
you do
well
one thing is you could just try and
create an ai agent like artificial
general intelligence in your own image
as closely as possible yeah so that it's
like your ear and just kind of rules
or instead you could say look there are
certain constraints i want for the world
yes and that will be in the power of
this like very powerful artificial
intelligence right that's the kind of ai
constitution i was imagining so if my
ideology was that
the only books anyone should ever read
are books by brandon sanderson i could
theoretically make that a law and
enforce it through
some kind of ai agent that eliminates
anything that is not fantasy
exactly
exactly and is enforcing that eternally
because it's immortal essentially and so
that's why even if
we avoid this issue the
risk of kind of misaligned takeover by
ais themselves
we still have this possible opportunity
possible choice moment which is a choice
moment for the whole future of
civilization
between
do we use this power to create like a
liberal flourishing world where people
can pursue their own different moral
conceptions try and get to a point where
we've really like figured out what's
correct morally pursuing that or is it
the case that someone is taking power
using that ideology
and taking power and entrenching that
ideology yeah and then using these
immortal beings to enforce that ideology
for all time that is crucially important
because it means that well i spoke
earlier about these like two possible
worlds one is this flourishing liberal
world where everyone is free and
yeah can do what they want or this
others like all the powers in a single
dictator and the rest of all the other
beings in society are their slaves like
i think the point at which we get human
level or greater than human level
intelligence
could really be a hinge point between
those two futures and maybe kind of
everything in between as well okay what
do we do about this so what do we do
i think of a couple of things
what do we owe the future
what we are the future so on the kind of
misaligned like ai takeover worthy there
you can there's this huge kind of
technical research program now on
aligning ais with kind of human
uh values so basically ensuring that ai
systems do what you want them to do but
then ensuring that they do what you want
them to do even if they are much smarter
than you are so you can imagine
you're a child
and you have come to kind of rule a
country
and you're turning a point you need to
appoint some ruler in your place because
you know you're just a child and so
you're trying to like figure out which
of these adults who are much smarter and
better than form than you which are
lying to you which are just sycophants
such as schemers
or which are the ones that like actively
you know trying to make a flourishing
society
that's a big challenge and so in terms
of what you can do you can get a go into
machine learning get many people go and
do phds there and then start working on
this technical yeah the search probe
then yeah also can actually benefit
again from philosophers like the numbers
of philosophers involved because it's
still like it's such an early stage
field that benefits from philosophers
because they sit around and figure out
like what is the right moral thing to do
here actually more just like conceptual
clarity and like the nature of the
problem that we're facing and therefore
kind of what the best paths to
reducing that yeah to addressing that
problem
so that's kind of one set of things and
then the other big thing and it is messy
at the moment like
there is this big spectrum when it comes
to issues affecting the long term
there's a bit of a trade-off between
what are the things that may be most
important
and like really future shaping and what
are the things that are most selectable
there's something like you know climate
change clean energy
just robustly good very taxable we can
put like billions of dollars into this
everyone could be working on it so they
must be making the world better
and then the thing that i'm coming to is
like ai governance which is
okay we're getting more and more
powerful ai systems
yep who has control over them who has
power how is that power being shared
is there just like a race between the us
and china it's like a new arms race over
artificial general intelligence or is it
some collaborative thing
fairly messy
hard to know that you're making progress
in it but people can go into like policy
and government work and there's a bunch
of stuff happening there
that to try and make progress on this
problem it feels like there's all these
potential problems that have a pretty
high
biostandards probability of causing
significant problems in our lifetime
yeah and in a way like i think even even
for example the extinction extinction
extinction argument even if you don't
buy long-termism yeah for whatever
reason it's just like well
significant risk of like really bad
stuff happening to you and your lifetime
and your kids and your grandkids like
come on yeah within effective autism
this is a line of criticism over like
the book
um not like the content of the book but
there's a lot of people who just like
man these things will just kill us in
our lifetime or like have a significant
probability of that we don't need to go
via this detour yeah we're concerned
about future people yeah exactly and so
on the one hand i just like i want to
convey what i believe i think the like
fact that this is impacting the long
term future
is like really fundamental and maybe
we're confused about the pandemics maybe
confused by ai and change our mind in 10
years i want something robust to that on
the other hand maybe i'm just being a
philosopher then i'm like i'm writing
the stuff that's like
a philosopher finds important uh but
yeah i agree that like you don't need in
any way to
be a long termist you don't need to
think past hundreds of years
to think that the things that we're
focusing on are enormously important
yeah because yeah they're having like
very major impacts negative effects like
in our lives yeah so let's say someone's
listening to this and they're like right
i'm sold
this is like sounds scary as [ __ ] and i
need to do something about it maybe with
my career maybe with my money maybe with
my time
what what are the starting points okay i
think the single first thing to do
obviously other than leading the driver
future is it out yet officially we'll be
out but it comes out uh six yeah but by
the time this podcast is out it will
have been out uh 16th of august in the
us and the first of september in the uk
okay sweet beyond that i mean 80 000
hours i would say is the first stop um
so it was an organization that you know
takes this
paradigm of one thing worrying about
essential risks and long termism fairly
seriously indeed
and so it has recommended career paths
in areas like pandemic preparedness in
areas like ai safety and ai governance
as well as other areas like some of the
things we've talked about global health
and development and climate change and
so on so it's and it's got enormous
amounts of content there these long kind
of career profiles as well
so that's something
uh that's like probably like the first
place to go another book that's also
excellent like these two books are
complementary is the precipice by toby
ord i mentioned toby like at the start
of this podcast he was the person i
co-founded giving what we can with and
he goes into a lot of detail on these
catastrophic risks that we could be
facing
and then
for other sorts of
information
places that you can go open philanthropy
is a foundation that has
some kind of
really incredible kind of the search
reports and sometimes just blog posts on
just like different issues that they've
faced when um trying to make grants in
this area and issues that come up so
like i don't know looking at ai for
example
i've said artificial general
intelligence could plausibly come in our
lifetimes at what at what date and what
with what probability should we should
we think that will happen
they've put enormous amounts of work
into this so one was just this question
of how much computation does the human
brain use and they spent months and
months and months like interviewing all
the top neuroscientists trying to get
answers to that question
what does the trend in terms of cost for
a certain amount of computation cost
over time and what should we expect
investment to look like again put
enormous amount of research into that
and between that then created the model
to integrate that to try and figure out
okay this is approximately when we
should expect artificial general
intelligence to
um appear and you get significant
probabilities on that within the next 20
years and you get it happening like more
likely than not within our lifetimes so
yeah they have enormous amount of
research as well
and then for learning more more casually
there's the effect of altruism for them
um has discussion on
these kind of long-term topics and a lot
of other stuff that's going on too nice
and i guess if someone's like oh there's
all these causes and yeah those they all
seem good and you made a compelling case
for a lot of them it's like
how do i know which path to go down is
that by going on 80 000 hours and doing
my
figuring out my sort of personality type
and what i vibe with or uh yeah i mean i
think the first thing to do would be to
if you can try to reduce that
uncertainty so read these books leave 80
000 hours in depth play and get to grips
with it yourself
if it does come to the you come to the
conclusion like oh they all seem equally
good then yeah getting involved with 80
000 hours providing if you can try and
get career advice from them
and they can maybe guide you to
somewhere that you have a particularly
good fit yeah and it could be that the
thing you're best fit at like for you
for example if you're going to start
hosting more kind of things related to
effective altruism you can do that
across a wide variety of causes so yes
perhaps you can have your k can eat it
too you can yeah if you or me what would
you be doing let's say you've got this
platform you've got 3 million
subscribers of the main channel you've
got the podcast you can kind of access a
lot of people probably not everyone in
the world but like a lot of people for
an interview
what would what should i be doing to
maximize i guess impact i mean the very
most obvious thing is to do kind of two
you know move your
podcasts and youtube
in a direction such that you can
both keep growing it you're providing
the content that you know they leave
things people in getting
stuff exactly yeah and then at the same
time host people who you think are
expressing the most important ideas
where
my guess is that i mean it could be that
you just go all in
on most important ideas but potentially
yes my guess would be kill the goose
exactly yes uh lays the golden egg yes
if you did none of it though then i mean
i think a sort of advice helping people
live their best lives as you put it like
it's making the world better it's
probably not making the world better by
as much as getting people to stop the
next pandemic
and so there'll be some like ideal ways
middle way but you could thank that you
could look at like what's the sort of
conversion you get from
uh how to have a passive income versus
like yeah that's a very good idea yeah
first like we could we could almost do
because we do a bunch of roi analyses in
terms of like how much money the youtube
channel makes and stuff and then
sponsors obviously super interested in
that yeah but i guess we could make a
model that's like
what what is our impact as a youtube
channel and as an organization as a
whole absolutely because we got an email
from uh luke freeman who runs everyone
at the moment when i made a video about
it they got like i think within a few
week window an extra like million
dollars in pledges
and he was like oh that's however many
divided by 5000 lives that a single
video saved and that was like a really
badly performing video in the grand
scheme of things yeah so if we could do
more of that if we could
get more people
to talk to 80 000 hours and just just be
a little bit more thingy with their
career if we exactly yeah you spawned
the next sbf exactly you can expect that
impact yeah i mean and it's not crazy at
all that you would you know create
someone who's generating
you know billions of dollars worth of
value for good causes yeah and this is
this has happened in the past i mean
the other podcast interviews i've done
the most impactful of which was sam
havis um insignificant part because he
like you took the given what we can
pledge started giving every podcast he
did he gives five thousand dollars to i
mean he's now giving actually much more
than that but uh that was the start so
he could save a life that just meant
yeah enormous number of people took the
pledge got involved in the effect of
altruism and that's cool i didn't know
he did that i'll be like every podcast
episode saves life yeah exactly classic
that's great you could do this you could
do the same yeah let's look at the
finances yeah exactly and then just that
idea i i know like on james clear's
website at the bottom of it he had
donates whatever percent i think he's
taking founders pledge or something okay
one percent to the against malaria
foundation and it's like little tracker
then the footer of his blog about how to
build better habits it's like oh proceed
through my book sales have really have
saved 24 lives yeah which makes it a
very tangible yeah exactly very tangible
and yeah and it would make sense for you
as well to be covering a broad array of
causes i think if you were just kind of
pandemics in the eye of the yeah become
the tinfoil hand guy exactly oh yeah
exactly it's got particularly banned but
there's just like enormous numbers of
good things that people in effective
autism are doing yeah yeah you can
highlight the and there's also just like
demand i think for kind of positive
optimistic yeah stories about doing good
because how are you so cheerful about
this stuff it's weird it's funny isn't
it yeah oh yeah you know i put the risk
of like all that nuclear war 20
it's so funny because there's some
people on the spectrum of people worried
about these risks i'm like comparatively
optimistic like my um risk numbers are
quite low right there are some people in
particular in the bay area yeah who
think that
agi
90 is coming in the next 20 years let's
say
given that 99 that everyone dies
and some of them are just like yeah i'm
just a cheerleading guy by nature
while talking about this yeah so i think
this is another good example of like you
know the kind of doctor mindset where
you're just like
it's now a job and you just you just
kind of revert back to what your natural
personality is yeah but the war stuff
like
really gets me like i really like
wars is very common throughout history
you can read you can read about it yep
like millions of people have died
we were very close to nuclear war like
two cities in japan have been were nuked
yeah this like animosity between the us
and china is growing already india and
pakistan do not have good relationships
there was a war there was a skirmish
between india and china in 2020 yeah
june 2020 where people died like a fatal
skirmish between the two most populous
countries in the world like
this is not like i don't know the ai
stuff at least i can understand if
people like this feels like circulation
but like wars is a very real thing yeah
and it feels like viscerally very scary
to me but you stay cheerful because of
just like personality vibes and i guess
it's kind of nice to be able to talk
about this stuff in a nice well-lit room
yeah like to be like yeah we're human
extinction yeah well there's someone
perhaps if you do get more people more
guests on the searcher future of
humanity institute called anders
sandberg
and he's one of the most just broadly
knowledgeable people i've ever met yeah
and he often works on really just
thinking about like what worst case
scenarios so
cobalt bombs or like these kind of
uh which are like
possible designs of nuclear weapons that
would be like maximally destructive he's
also just the happiest person i maybe
know so he's just like cheerful like
joking about like oh yes and this is
yeah and i think like that's just his
personality and anders is just like a
joy yeah but yeah it can't like i do
need to be checked sometimes it's like
these are talking about like mortally
horrific and like very serious things so
the chief yeah like it's a balancing act
on model attitudes so what do you what
what does your day-to-day look like it's
a great question it's very weird at the
moment the last two years during the
pandemic so i'm often very split like
i'm a
you know philosophy professor i'm also
on the board and co-founders of a number
of non-profits i'm also like doing a lot
more outreach like this sort of thing
also doing like writing and research so
it's often kind of very split yeah when
the pandemic happened i had this
two-year period almost of just like
i was just like this is the best time
yeah i will ever have in my life to
write a book and so this is going to be
the biggie this is what i'm really
working on yeah that day to day was very
different than it is now that day to day
was yeah waking up at 7 00 am or 8 a.m
and you know make myself a nice like
flat white coffee or something and i'd
have like two
two kind of intense lighting periods
yeah like three hours in the morning in
the afternoon um maybe do some other
stuff outside of that and make sure i
like yeah work out every day yeah have
like a nice long lunch break because for
lighting as well it's more about like
peak performance my hours weren't that
high
what does your writing process look like
like what do what if i because i'm
writing books
just like trying to figure out anything
any magic secret sauce other than just
sit down and write okay yeah
i actually need to do uh i mean that's
by far the biggest thing yeah i'm
laughing because i once got lighting
advice and um from a friend i won't name
him but i think he'll be fine he's a
best-selling author and he was giving me
all this advice it's very standard
advice like um
you know write every day do it first
thing in the morning have like blocked
time focus on input goals and i was like
okay cool i'm not learning very much and
he was like oh and i'm drunk
oh yeah i just drink wine
just like every day
he's not an alcoholic but it's just like
it helps him so for me i got pretty
intense about optimizing things
so i definitely figure out when you do
your best work
i think most of my value of my day is in
the first three hours okay so i try and
not check anything i'd have three hours
then in the afternoon it can be a little
bit more chill like maybe it's a bit
more like reading in the search every
evening
i would check in with my chief of staff
at the time who's kind of so i had a
whole team kind of working on this but
yeah and with her we would review the
day yeah so well we would set goals for
the next day so to set input goals and
output goals okay i would slack the
amount of time i was lighting i wouldn't
snack anything else so the only number i
was having in terms of my inputs were
just writing goals because everything
else was less important
um
input versus output do you mean do we
mean input is um how many hours i spent
writing i see an upwards how many would
you create yes or it would be more
sections so i'd say like tomorrow i'm
going to do six hours of writing yeah
that would i count that like a full day
it wouldn't be very often i'd do more
hours of writing than that okay and then
i would say i want to write these four
sections or these three sections okay
and so every day she would hold me to
that like ask if i've done it if not
like why yeah the accountability exactly
and it's really huge so deadlines are
just very big
it used to be that when i had a writing
deadline i would post on facebook
i would say if you
if i don't submit this paper by this
date
then i will give 50
to
and then at the time i was like i'm
looking for someone you know i posted on
facebook like 50 to the first person to
message or something
and you need to spend it on something i
don't approve of and so
a couple of people who eat meat
were like okay yeah i will take that and
i'll spend it on boneless chicken thighs
and i'm like vegetarian
and there was one week i worked like a
hundred hours like i worked through the
night because i was like there's i just
cannot give this person money to buy
chicken so it's extremely effective
as people some people judge me on
facebook for being a weirdo but yeah i
find these kind of deadlines extremely
effective because
writing more than anything is like
psychological hurdles it's easy to
procrastinate yeah if you have goals you
can really get through it
then i'm also very heavy on
just getting words on the page and it's
shitty you know just write something and
then the visor afterwards i think
looking back i maybe wish that
i did a bit more of like figuring out
the kind of logical structure because
it's kind of
this book was a real challenge in many
ways but one of the reason it's a
challenge is
it's trying to do two things
one is be like something that's moving
the state of the front like our
knowledge frontier forwards so there's
like a lot in that book that's like you
know novel work that you can't find even
in academic journals or elsewhere but
yet at the same time be this like
broadly accessible introduction to these
ideas and normally those things like
really which they don't
and so
i did think about the book kind of
that when i was thinking about the book
i was like okay if i'm gonna fail in one
direction like probably i'm going to
fail in like not being
accessible understandable enough so i
really went heavily on that
but then it meant that sometimes
structures of the chapter is like oh
this works narratively yeah but like
people are getting a bit confused about
the logical argument and so you actually
can notice it through the course of the
book where chapters eight and nine which
are just like philosophy
which i've put towards the end because
it's like for the advanced leader who
really wants to dig in
there the like structure of the chapter
is not much more clear because they're
absolutely logical because i was like
less worried about the innovative kind
of things and there was also a bit of an
issue that sometimes i'm like oh this
would make for a really good narrative
and it's based on maybe certain studies
yep and then i like
got a search assistant to like try and
replicate the studies and like it's like
oh it doesn't check out and i'm like oh
it's annoying yeah it's annoying for the
narrative it's so nice if this was true
there's so many things that were so nice
if they would have been through yeah but
yeah this is
you know as i mentioned before this
forecast uh
yeah we did an hour of
sorry it did
like at least a couple of years like
probably a couple of years worth of time
just fact checking
but yeah so in terms of that's the
process a huge thing is just no other
commitments yep so i some people are
able to like write in the morning and
then do other stuff in the afternoon
yeah i've been trying that for me
for me i just need long
chunks of time yeah and so
for both doing good better and this it's
like i just disappear from the world
yeah for doing good better that was
about six months for this book it was a
year and a half if i'm doing two things
i'm like yeah because the part of the
issue is like everything else is more
salient than writing a book yeah so what
you're thinking about in the shower
if there's something else going on your
brain's thinking about that yeah you're
not thinking about the work yeah and
then i got absurd amounts of feedback on
it as well okay so i had two
yeah that's like i had two big feedback
rounds
well no actually and it essentially had
three so to begin with i uh prepared a
talk it was like the core ideas yeah and
went on a speaking tour yep because i
just i wanted to be kind of
startup advice talk to your users i
wanted to
really get in the habit presenting these
ideas getting feedback on what what
resonated and what didn't that was
before writing the book
then i looked after the first five
chapters got intensive feedback on that
yep again it's maybe like 40 50 people
provided in-depth comments
and then i'd written an entire first
draft of the book
after that feedback round
six months later after that
and then
again it was maybe even more like
i wouldn't be surprised if it was
closing in on a hundred people who like
provided
comments and feedback on it okay
lots of work yeah
and then and what's your book going to
be about it's basically about how to do
more of the things that really matter to
you by harnessing energy from the stuff
that you're doing anyway okay fantastic
like sustainable productivity and how to
make it fun and sustainable and
different stuff because then a question
for you i don't know if you're gonna
have a team but something is unusual
about this book is i had like a team of
people
like i was obviously the author no one's
contributed more to book than me but i
had
researchers that had employed i had this
like large network of contractors and
consultants
so
there's tons of history in there i'm not
historian i did spend like i've had a
lot of history because i really wanted
to get up to speed on it but i had a
historian who was like on contract and
the reason i focus on slavery is that
for so much of chapter three is that i
was asking i asked him like what are
some examples of historical events that
seemed very important but yet were
not inevitable could have gone either
way and he came back and he was like i
think the abolition of slavery and i was
like that seems totally mad i thought
that was just like inevitable
development he's like no actually like
historical
mainstream historical view is like it's
actually uh
could have gone either way
again it's like you know how to know but
like this is not you know within his
history it's not like
it's not a niche opinion exactly and so
man i got really obsessed by that and
like really dug into it but then also
climate change it's just we haven't
really talked about climate change we
haven't really talked about climate
change what's the deal with climate
change
while we're here because i did have a
written down as like something to ask
you about okay for sure and um i
actually maybe spent more time on
climate change than anything else even
though it doesn't make a huge appearance
in the book well just because there's
like this huge economic literature and
huge science literature to really kind
of dive in on
so i mean the way i put it in the book
is decarbonization in particular via
funding
innovation and clean energy yup i
consider it like the baseline
long-termist activity okay the baseline
exactly so it's like if you're doing
nothing else you should at least do this
exactly yeah it's like this alone kind
of i would say like proves long termism
and then or
as i define it and then maybe you can do
even more
and why do i think of it as a baseline
well in the book i describe clean energy
innovation as a win win win win win okay
and i now actually wish i think there's
a sixth win
that i should have put in but why is
that so like even if you're just looking
in the near term just people lives a day
burning fossil fuels kills three and a
half million people a year oh um what
health uh particulates so air pollution
is
this enormous health cost that people
barely talk about so even within europe
very unpolluted part of the world we
lose about a year of life expectancy
just due to the particulates from
uh fossil fuel burning
and when economists do the analysis
they tend to find that even if you're
just looking at the health costs they're
like near-term health costs you've got
an argument for like very rapidly
decarbonizing the world economy right
so that's that's one yeah second over
the kind of medium term is obviously the
climate change impact which yeah we all
know and understand very well of course
yeah third is if you're doing it via
clean tech you can like decrease energy
poverty not energy poverty just that um
people in poor countries like have very
limited access so if you build solar
panels on their houses exactly yeah also
if you can just make energy cheaper what
you're doing you're also just advancing
technological progress so we haven't
talked about technological stagnation i
have a chapter in the book about that i
think that's a big deal and a big worthy
too but we can
so there weren't enough i wasn't
worrying you enough
there's nothing to worry about yeah
there's just more there yeah but then in
the more distinctively long-termist ways
i think that i think the clean energy
tech helps with both extending the
lifespan of um civilization and then the
sixth thing that i didn't really talk
about is like i think it's good for val
values perspective from the long run too
so on the extending life of civilization
lifespan of civilization imagine a
catastrophe that doesn't result in human
extinction
but does is so bad that it kind of sends
us back to the industrial levels of
technology yep so perhaps it kills 99.9
of the world population there's a
question would we recover from that as
in
would we just stay as farmers forever or
would we redevelop um science and indus
like post-industrial technology and
again i have a chapter in this book
discussing that question okay i actually
come out very optimistic okay i think
it's like actually very very likely that
we wanted to just go back to the stone
agent forever we would be able to
reinvent exactly we would be able to
reinvent this microphone at some point
at some point yeah and part like there's
many many considerations there but one
is just looking at like what are the
potential blockers like is there any
like resource that we like have used up
now that like
we wouldn't otherwise have that seems
kind of essential
and there's nothing that really is like
remotely plausible to be essential that
we have used up or might plausibly use
up with one exception which is fossil
fuels
where we obviously like in terms of
easily accessible oil we've basically
used that all up yeah
easily accessible coal we still have
like 300 years to go okay nonetheless
like if you told me that it's 300 years
time and we've burned through all easily
accessible coal
i'm not like totally shocked i think
it's unlikely i think we are just
transitioning away from fossil fuels i'm
like actually pretty optimistic on the
progress we're making but it still just
provides us like extra reason to keep
fossil fuels in the ground
which is in case we need them at a later
date exactly we can dig them up fairly
easily right then trying to build a
fracking distillery that like yeah which
would be impossible with like 17 how
you're going to do that yeah uh 18th
century technology yeah so this is kind
of like this additional reason it's like
a last resort last resort exactly yeah
like civilization emergency
civilizational insurance it like helps
the
civilization
then the final thing which is the thing
i like didn't include is like the
pathway via values
where the invasion of ukraine has just
made this like much more salient
countries that lie
very heavily for the gdp on oil
and gas and coal often
actually no i'll flip it the other way
among the countries that seem like the
scariest in terms of their governance
yes they often and yet are powerful yes
and like um economically developed
how do they manage to do those both of
those things typically it's because they
have enormous fossil fuel reserves and
they're selling fossil fuels yeah so
they can so people exactly so some
people describe russia as a gas station
with a military oh well that's like
how you should understand it okay
similarly with kind of yeah some of the
more worthy kind of uh gulf state
countries or dictatorships that get set
up and um africa as well so there's this
thing of the resource curse where in
it's like a phenomenon noted by
economists where among very poor
countries especially looking at africa
those countries with the best natural
resource deposits
tended to have the worst economic
performance
because there's an incentive for a
military coup take power become a
dictatorship
extract
natural resource wealth they can use
that to prop themselves up yeah they
don't need to like
listen to build technology and stuff
because
exactly or or have a democracy here and
so the final thing is just like you move
on fossil fuels you decreased that um
yeah six wins exactly so i think of
clean energy tech as very unusual in
this space in that it's like it's very
robustly good i've given you these six
different perspectives and it looks good
on all of them and then secondly it's
just an area where
we really understand what's going on as
well like the health pollution the like
the fact that advances technology
technology the impacts on climate change
like this is not like a speculative area
and then finally why is it a baseline we
could just dump like tens of billions of
dollars into this
yeah able to resolve that and do
something useful with it exactly yeah
whereas these some of these other areas
it's like okay they're very underfunded
at the moment they've got like tens of
millions of dollars like
how much can we scale that up it's like
it's unclear like probably we can but
like it's at least not as obvious nice
yeah um the idea of sustainable
productivity the
vague structure from my book is as
follows i the the the top level idea is
that really the secret to
sustainable productivity is to find a
way to get energy from the things that
you do so that you can give more energy
to the things that you love to do
or something like that
some level of wordsmithing yeah so three
parts of the book classic part of the
sort of three part structure part one is
called energize and it's about the three
energizers yeah three p's of power play
and people which are the things that
make anything that we do whatever
whether it's work or projects or chores
yeah more energizing
then part two is like okay you've got
that energy or like
it's all it's all well and good that
stuff energizing you once you're doing
it but a lot of people struggle to get
started and so those are about the three
blockers that cause procrastination okay
so we've called it we're calling those
obscurity
anxiety and inertia obscurity basically
like goal is not particularly yeah yeah
clarity etc anxiety like self-doubt and
all that crap and then inertia just
can't be asked to get started and the
final part of the book is sustain
so it's like in part one energize part
two unblock part three sustain so how do
we make this all sustainable so one
chapter about like the idea of
consistency and just seeing seeing
things through to the end another
chapter about recovery and rest and
stuff and how that relates to burnout
and how we think about rest and recovery
and recharging in the final chapter
about like purpose and meaning and nice
stuff as like the ultimate thing that
makes anything sustainable if you
believe in if you're working for a
course that you really care about we'd
love to hear just any thoughts on that
structure that idea anything that come
to mind anything that sparks that i can
follow up as like a a book
recommendation or anything like that
okay sure i mean like in terms of i mean
so obviously you'll would make a plug
for ea being in the final chapter
i mean i'm sure you know the
procrastination equation a second thing
one thing is just like i mean as you i'm
sure you know like what's the value of a
book it's like no one reads books what
happens though is like you have a it
like builds up brand and cache and you
run ideas and
yeah what did you call it lead magnet
lead magnet exactly and so this is
exactly right and people are like oh
this book and they've got this thing to
hang on
and so then it's like there just needs
to be like one idea that's like yep
very magnetic and
memorable and so like one story or
something i don't know if you have that
yet but like
think about that it's like fifty percent
of the value of the or something like
one story if you spend half your time
just getting that one story so that
unfortunately i actually don't have this
for this and this is like a major issue
and i'm still trying to think about like
what
what can work there
but
yeah peter singers like drowning child
yep analogy you know in this original
article that takes up two sentences i
think everyone remembers everyone
remembers like so do you know made to
stick
yes i haven't read it by the chip and
dan heath yeah extremely good book one
of my favorite books and it's about how
you like sticky ideas and it's just like
very powerful it's almost always stories
so if you can get like
two famous people
one of whom like horrifically burned out
and the other one just like had this
like long-running success over time i
know like arnold schwarzenegger or
something
how did it keep going for 90 years yeah
exactly yeah that's like ideal it's like
you've got this like 90 yeah
80 year olds who's still like crushing
it like like how yeah that's a good show
then that's like really memorable nice
and that's much more memorable like you
gave me these ppp if not yeah i've
forgotten it already
yeah story yeah yeah but there's just
it's one opening story and you will say
it a thousand times yeah in all the
podcasts and all things exactly and yeah
that's the thing that people will hear
and they'll be like okay ali abdul this
book yeah it's that story yeah and then
like that's the
again most of the value like so that's a
big thing and that's natural naturally
it's the thing you lead with as well
like and appears in an excerpt in terms
of the content of it it's kind of
interesting like
i'm just not sure how true it has been
for me that i like get energy from one
set of things and that like transfers
over to being energetic about other
things
yeah so in a way it's like that that
causal link is is not quite what we're
trying to say okay what we're trying to
say is that like it's really hard to be
productive
in a sustainable fashion if the thing
that you are actually doing
really drains your energy yeah and so
let's figure out a way to make it more
energizing okay okay
as almost as as a side effect of
incorporating autonomy and like a sense
of play and people and accountability
and stuff into your work okay you'll be
more productive about the thing but
you'll also be more like motivated at
the end of the workday for example you
don't like your job yeah okay so it's
kind of like
a manual for improving
in practice improving grit like
improving ability to achieve like large
projects over a long time essentially
that so that could be another story as
if there is someone who's like
they achieved something that's very
impressive but took like 20 years yeah
that would be like a very good story
it's like and then how did they do that
okay that is something which is like
resonated with me
i like find it like why have i been
successful i'm like kind of confused by
it i mean obviously a big part of it is
luck yes i think one thing i do do is
like
i have long term goals that i really
work towards
the other people
i don't know like
like writing a book especially like this
is like a real effort book yeah it does
involve just like you're plugging away
at something over the very long time
period yeah and there's lots of people
who i think like have the ability to
write such a book but like
lots of people just don't yeah and so
what's going on there one is like
yeah that like you say feeling of
purpose like i just feel morally
motivated i'm like
if i'm slacking off like yeah that's
important the world is getting worse
yeah um obviously easier to do when it's
like poor people in
sub-saharan africa than existential
threats can be like a little bit harder
to visualize but nonetheless i'm still
just like okay this is motivated i
should push myself every day morally
motivating
what does the goal look like is it like
an input goal or is it like an outcome
goal or is it like i want the book to
hit x number of sales or like oh i mean
my goal is much bigger than the book i
have a vision for the world where
everyone has this kind of shared goal of
just making the world better yeah and
it's just agreed we've got this like
impartial goal yeah and everyone's just
willing to reason about it and that's
understood to be just like part of
living a good model life
in the same way as like not being a
racist and you know not like murdering
and so on yeah and i'm just like that is
achievable like we could have that world
rather than the world where it's like us
versus china and like yeah the you know
the woke and the anti-work and
everyone's fighting and i'm like no
instead it's kind of like like within ea
is just like you've got all of these
people they're like okay we want to do
as much good as possible we believe in
like reason and argument as the way of
like figuring out things and it's like
people can have disagreements but
there's always this feeling of like
shared project and i'm like okay i want
to just expand that to the world as a
whole yeah and i'm like okay how do we
get there and then it's like well one
path on this and like obviously i'm just
trying to move the world in that
direction but one path in that direction
is you know having a book and convincing
more people and that's like
that's motivating and then like there's
some a sub-goal of like okay i want you
know when i was lighting it i definitely
wasn't thinking about this now it's like
campaign mode or something like okay i
want to be on the new york times
bestseller so like what would it involve
yeah when i was like actually writing
the book the sub goal was more just like
i want to write i guess i like want to
write something that i'm like still kind
of happy with when i die or like yeah i
want to write something it's like the
obituary is like yeah will mccaskill
who's about what we are the future like
okay i was like this is the output i
wanted for like so i think there's yeah
so i was yeah much more focused on just
like how can i how can i create the kind
of
most important book i can yeah so it's
like during the process of it
because i think
for me with the book like if i think too
much about the new york times bestseller
list it demotivates me to write the book
because it's just oh yeah pressure yeah
i really wasn't thinking about that yeah
also it doesn't matter like no one reads
the book yeah it's kind of like
that means i mean again like go to
chapter eight like it gets pretty
technical endnotes they got us to put a
lot online but still like a big chunk of
the book like i got to do all of the
like nerdy like
intellectual content i wanted to put in
there because it's like not that many
people will make it to chapter 8 yeah
those that do will be interesting yes
yeah so it's actually kind of liberating
you can like partly do it for you
so
yeah why do i think i'm like good at
like longer term aims i think a big
thing is like having a vision that i
ultimately want to achieve
and then it's like this backward
induction of like okay so we've got to
do this thing and this thing and this
thing yeah and that ties to like now
like therefore tomorrow we've got to do
like three hours of lighting in the
morning what do you what do you find
helpful when you find yourself
procrastinating normally the the main
thing i'm the main thing i want to say
is like structuring my life so i don't
procrastinate there's three phones yeah
what to do with three phones
uh so
i used to have one phone yes i used to
procrastinate a lot cool i am like have
a horrifically addictive personality
it's like there's always got to be
something that can be computed like
computer ninja whatever um facebook
twitter
reddit bbc that's kind of one set of
things another is just like
which is just also very common is always
wanting to check email or messages or
like some stressful work thing and
therefore like not getting a work-life
balance whereas i'm like extremely
in favor of just like hard lines between
like are you
are you using time that's optimized for
time off or using time that's optimized
for work like there's nothing in between
i think that's a very bad state to be in
so because i guess in between you're
sort of half doing like i should be
doing work but yeah lots of people do
this like even since uni i was like yeah
people are like oh i'm in a lively but
i'm also chatting yeah i'm just like
what is this yeah or the worst is if
it's like oh it's my day off but i'll do
a bit of work and so it's like no just
do one thing on the other yeah why do
you find that helpful why do i find that
helpful yeah i just think you get the
worst of both worlds you're neither most
productive nor
having the most enjoyment if you're like
doing something that's like half work
okay half enjoyable okay whereas you
want like
you want chunks of like pure
rejuvenation time yes
and then when you're working
i mean in general there's this
underlying view which also underlies a
lot of effective altruism which is like
most values in the tails
so like it's the same like light like
goes into the 80 20 overall but um yeah
if there are like 10 things you do you
could do do all 10 like how much value
comes from the best one how much value
comes from the worst one maybe it's one
percent from the best one like 50 from
the
best one yeah that's through for leisure
then like
of all the good things you could do yeah
like with your time off like if you're
doing something that's kind of crappy
maybe that's like 10 times worse yeah
some in terms of how rejuvenating it is
than something that's best similarly
when you're working like if you're like
oh i'm doing this half work yeah it's
probably just like no
you
should just focus on the best thing
actually that leads to another like a
bit of like a guiding motto
or like productivity technique for me is
i call it eat that elephant
so do you know the book eat that flag so
yeah the idea is you have some time like
three hours and you just the most
hardest thing you just do that eat that
elephant is like that but for much
larger tasks and so i'm normally like
nothing there's just something that's
the most important thing yeah do nothing
else until you have finished that most
important thing and maybe that's like
two weeks and you've got this like
enormous index like inbox and you've not
responded to any of your emails but now
you've done that most important thing
maybe it's an entire book maybe yeah um
now i'm in a situation where it's like
you know i have this team around me so i
can like still handle those other things
and things don't clash
but it definitely like prior to that
which is most of the time it would
instead just be like okay dropping
everything so like completely zooming in
this most important thing and i think
that's like really or like i guess the
future fun was kind of like that as well
it's like i had this whole plan that's
like nope there's this new foundation
like i'm kind i didn't quite pop
everything it's like haven't i yeah
manage everything but i'm now focusing
on this thing yeah and i think it's
served me really well because people
just don't i think people aren't willing
to like switch um enough yeah so a big
thing is just structuring my environment
so that the class
it's hard to procrastinate okay so i
have a work phone yep that has email
slack work email slack signal which i
use for other messages and then i have a
personal phone which doesn't have those
things but has other things and then i
have this like old crappy phone that
takes ages to load up and that has like
indulgences
and actually since i've had the phone
i've basically never used it like almost
never use it but like if they were like
if i was like oh i really want to play
this iphone game then it would be on
that phone and it lives in like a in
like a door
and so it's like i can still play it any
time i want yeah i just have to load it
up it's got like a brutal effects screen
just have to load it up and wait the
five ten minutes that it takes to load
because it's this old phone like get it
from the toilet yeah so that's
essentially equivalent to work phone
personal phone and like a games console
yeah i guess so yeah i can intend to
switch or something exactly like i've
got one and i haven't used it in years
because it's just in the drawer and i i
know i always could use it if i wanted
to but i cannot yeah so i think they're
like how do you overcome procrastination
the main thing is like
don't be put in a position such that you
can procrastinate so like similarly like
how do i avoid eating sugary food or
something is like don't have sugary food
around the other thing but then
yeah it's impossible to avoid all forms
procrastination
yeah the accountability stuff has been
by far and away the biggest thing and
touch tracking time
when i've been writing yep um otherwise
it's so easy to procrastinate so like
input time and output time so input
literally just number of hours yeah so
do you mean like output goals yeah like
oh from 9 to 12 i was writing or do you
mean like from 901 to 9 18 i was using
google docs therefore i was writing yeah
as in i've got toggle slack on my
computer so it's like
i press it if i go to the bathroom it
goes off okay um so that three hours is
like really fact hours like i take a
break it goes off and i start again oh
and i'm normally like so it's like
actually three whole hours yeah yeah no
actually hold on probably four hours of
like exactly yeah it'd be about four
hours so like okay yeah typically
i'd be so productive if i did that yeah
if it was like and you really noticed
people take a lot longer breaks than
they yeah then they would realize
otherwise so yeah typically during a
pandemic when i was lighting i would um
yeah it would be something like eight to
twelve three hours of lighting
and then like yeah two till six
three hours of lighting
and then like a little few other things
in there nice evening after that
and then ending at seven
final question i guess on this front is
like power play and people essentially
basically power being a combination of
autonomy and mastery yeah taking pride
taking control taking responsibility of
the thing that you're doing yeah because
weirdly somewhat somewhat
counterintuitively i hope uh putting
more energy actually gets you more out
of it yeah whereas if you're disengaged
with your work and you just put the bare
minimum and you're actually just
sucking life out of yourself uh play
basically just like uh tracking progress
with like little progress bar like
they're doing video games yeah yeah but
also kind of treating things with uh
being like
sincere rather than serious approaching
things with lightness and ease and just
in the spirit of play and finally people
finding a way to ask for help from
others finding a way to help others and
finding a way to sort of work with
others through accountability and things
like that anything come to mind like
stories from your life or anything like
that where you're like oh i i did this
thing and this really helped
yeah it's interesting with the people it
was a little different than how i would
describe it yeah for me it's just like
if you're around high-performing people
you perform better so like humans are
like imitators and we imitate like it's
actually really remarkable even
comparing to other primates we like
imitate even in cases where we don't
understand what's going on right um
whereas monkeys like or apes like
they need to know why someone's doing
like another ape is doing something
before they will imitate that yeah but
we just imitate anything that's
happening so yeah and that just means
like if you're surrounded by just like
really hard-working high-performing
people who are really focused yeah you
just start doing the same and if other
people are like blazing around you just
start doing the same yeah that's just
true for all of us and so when you said
people i thought it was going to be more
via this mechanism that's much less kind
of formal or much less like to find and
it's more like picking up the vibe it's
huge though culture's just huge so
that's the thing i was going to say
other things oh one meta thought do you
know ben todd he's the sister um yeah
he's the co-founder of a co-founded
eight thousand hours with him
i think
firstly i just think you get on really
really well he's also just the person
who's thought most about this stuff that
i know nice would be exactly
he would love that so yeah is he best in
the uk yes
his office is 10 minutes incredible yeah
that'll be so good and he's in fact
writing a book now because he was
running 80 000 hours and has now
moved into pleasant role so he can like
focus more on writing and once i have a
book but like he's really deep on the
productivity stuff and
also how that impacts his whole your
whole life so oh glorious and he's like
really on top of the evidence of it uh
perfect yeah i think you'll get one
really well yeah can you do an intro
absolutely yeah i think that'd be
awesome yeah in terms of things that
have really made a big difference like
medication so
antidepressant medication like because
you're depressed or because you mind the
migraines no i mean i started on
antidepressants because i was depressed
from like 2011 and then switched to this
particular type because of migraines
right but yeah just like you know there
are many pat like procrastination
yeah is like
it's a psychological phenomenon but like
the main you don't need a psychological
response or something it's like
um and like loads of people i know have
just like enormously benefited and like
i honestly think that people shouldn't
necessarily be in the mindset of like am
i depressed or not like rather they
should be like
if i consume this
pill will it have a net positive impact
on my life
again it's not necessarily the months
that the doctors always have but i know
other people who are just like i don't
know maybe they're mildly depressed and
then started in particular welbeck then
um
well but then so it's an antidepressant
um it's prescribed only for smoking
cessation in the uk in the u.s it's
prescribed for as an antidepressant it's
one of the lead ones actually right it's
a very different mechanism than
ssris um
and
it is also like people find it just
particularly good in particular like
it's like high energy it was kind of
when it was first developed in the u.s
again u.s like medical advertising it
was marketed as like the happy horny
skinny pill um because uh it doesn't
have the normal anti-libido effects it
can actually have weight gain yeah but
actually it's also like can be like good
for just like high energy and focus
similarly like a lot of people i know
who yeah were like struggled with the
stuff ages and then got diagnosed with
adhd that's just like
huge like now that on like medication
it's just like oh yeah that that's
interesting the problem of the past in
terms of other things i've done i mean
yeah another one is just like being on
top of my mood like
you described me as yeah do you like
questionnaire yourself or something or
like how do you i now like because i was
working so hard i like i was
there was a point
maybe a month ago or something or month
and a half ago that i was like okay i'm
clearly on this like burn out subject to
these so i started like monitoring my
mood and a bunch of other indicators and
over time i'm gonna see like how it how
it all correlates what were those
indicators that you're monitoring all
right how did you monitor your image uh
yeah so i just have a spreadsheet okay
it's got dates and then what do i put in
i put in my mood my productivity my
number of hours worked i put in whether
i've been traveling i put in my location
i put in whether i'm in the same
location as my partner
i put in whether my partner's feeling
sad because again i just predict that
that has a big impact on me i put in
whether like did i have a nap did i
exercise did i meditate
uh how much caffeine did i drink and
then i also like i think there might be
some other things and then i also put in
um qualitative comments as well and so
i'm going to look see see what other
patterns over time
you've done this all the time just like
when you sense yourself on a burnout
trajectory you're like yeah i've just
this is a new thing that i'm trying out
of a few weeks ago but i think it's
actually already helpful even just for
the like hey this is now something i'm
monitoring and thinking about so finally
i want to ask you about is completely
different is and i'm again asking
selfishly like what how do you think
about the balance between sort of your
personal income versus the money that is
in the business to like
in the business whatever your business
looks like to hire people and
researchers and all that stuff oh okay i
mean i think that's maybe a weird maybe
i'm not the person to advise or
something because my personal i've just
got this cap and then it's just all
in a sense it's like all either in the
business or going to charity or like
okay as in yeah so like like in our case
we have a bunch of cash in the business
basically yeah which is currently not
being put to very much use yep and even
though i take money out of the business
there's still like way more in the
business than i physically need to live
on it's like what i'm thinking is
what we do with that yeah if we donated
100 to charity it's like well then
there's not operating capital oh for
sure yeah it's just okay yeah i think um
well i think in the first interesting
one
yeah um no it's cool i don't know bonus
material or something like after that i
mean yeah if i were you i would think of
it as kind of a failing that you're
have this money in the bank and you
haven't thought of a way of like turning
it into more success
like
um i'd be like okay if i'm not doing
this i'm like screwing up in some way
where
yeah i don't know like
i would think something like
can you be getting
like let's say a 15 return on this like
10 15 return on this if not then maybe
donate it
but like so like there's this hard
question of like yeah at what point do
you like keeping i mean it actually
might be higher fee like even a lower
bar for you because
you're not going to be
like your path to impact assuming you
get on board with like bringing yeah
people on the show and so on absolutely
but yeah your path to impact is not
gonna be
via making money it's instead like you
want to build up this thing yeah we
could like start putting some numbers on
it but anyway there's going to be some
rate of the turn that you can get from
so you've got the cash yeah if you put
it i mean put it in a bank at the moment
you get point one percent
then hopefully you'll it's on sale at
the moment yeah
snp on average it's like five percent
per year real seems like you're on to a
good thing i think you should be able to
get better returns than that
where like at what rate of the turn
should you switch from like in order to
maximize your impact donating it rather
than that's a good point yeah investors
we probably have way more we it's just
like i just haven't thought about the
question of like what what is the goal
here yeah um in my mind is vaguely i
help people live their best life yeah
like there's no
yeah yeah yeah i mean my best yeah my
best guess is that like if you're
genuinely
going to be trying to use this platform
to move people into effective autism
stuff to a first approximation just try
and grow this as much as possible and
try and work as much try and grow the
business and your profile as much as
possible
and like invest
oh yeah here's a way of thinking about
it like we spend money that is a loss
just like straightforward loss
in order to get more people engaged with
effective altruism like there's no other
turn insofar as you're doing something
that has like yeah okay so the answer
might well be that you should be
spending all of the cash and more like
you should be like asking for
asking for grants to like oh and can i
go even further grant to a foundation to
be like hey this is this is the impact
that we're having yeah exactly exactly
yeah we need more money to be able to do
the thing yeah so
yeah yeah as for like what's the best
way of spending that like is it more the
searches is it like more marketing um
i don't i don't know because in my mind
i'm kind of thinking that oh i want to
run a 60 profit margin whether i want to
run no wait that doesn't make any sense
yeah it's an arbitrary number of plucked
out thin air because it gives me
the sense of psychological safety that
like oh like yeah there's a couple
million in the bank and i don't need to
touch it okay yeah
yeah look at amazon like what was its
profits
like years and years it was the other
yeah
and that's like why
yeah like and it makes sense like what
are the companies that are going to get
biggest it's like those that just like
ruthlessly reinvest what they've made
okay and you sit down and think about
this we've got them here and they will
come out for dinner tonight and this is
also okay yeah this also um
is a difference between if you're trying
to optimize for impact versus income so
yeah you might think like okay got a
couple of million in the bank now
i'm just going to be happy with that
like i can just seek that out like
additional money's not worth that much
more and because you've got like
is it female in youtube subscribers
about that okay yeah so you're like if i
had six million i'd have a bit more
money but it's not going to be a huge
difference in my well-being i don't i'm
not particularly motivated to grow the
numbers except i don't have like an
impact goal exactly but now if you're
having impacts yeah how much better the
six million subscribers than a female
yeah way better probably about twice as
good like maybe not exactly like but
like to first approximation yeah and so
having altruistic impact in mind gives
like much stronger arguments for scaling
yes than merely um financial yeah cause
that's the thing it's like the more we
scale the more headache i have because
it's like more people
oh like yeah yeah and even though we've
got now got management and stuff it's
still like not the same as
not the same level of speed as me just
doing stuff myself with like a team of
three people oh right yeah but obviously
the scale helps that the things that
i've always been currently it's been a
battle between like scaling the business
but like what's the point because i
don't need more money yeah
but if it's like the point is actually
in fact exactly yeah now there's a
reason to do the thing yeah absolutely
and in a way just even and entertaining
that thought makes it feel like way more
fun yeah exactly it's also like yeah
let's get a team of 50 people if we can
we can sustain it yeah i mean because
also like i don't know do you really
want to have a lifestyle business which
is just like come on it's not as cool as
like
i don't know like what's your long-run
name like i don't know i think i i i'm
not sure how to think of that yeah
because part of me is like i mean i just
would love to spend my if i again if i
won the lottery i would just spend my
time reading writing teaching yeah
learning about cool [ __ ] making videos
about it yeah writing books
yes which is all the stuff i do anyway
yeah yeah i just won't bother making any
more courses i just put them online for
free because
the only reason we make courses is to
make money yeah i don't know how to
figure out the question of like what is
my aim yeah okay how should i get it
but yeah i mean it's kind of interesting
with you know
youtubers like what's the like
i guess like the real ups upside is like
you have like a media company it's like
participant yeah do you know participant
media no
so it's like a it's a fun it's basically
a fund that
can funds movies that have social impact
oh so do you know the film contagion yes
that was already yeah that's like a
social enterprise um funded thing it's
by jeff skull one of the ebay
co-founders so similarly like the iphone
game plague the board game pandemic oh
yeah
why was there so much stuff about
pandemics beforehand yep yeah and for if
only people paid more attention yeah but
yeah but you could do that like a much
larger scale do you know phillip detmer
kurtz kazagt oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
the williams ea as well we've been
working with him
he's got more in the pipeline as well so
nice yeah you should definitely meet as
well yeah but yeah so it's worth
thinking about like yeah what's the real
upside yeah and i think probably
it is just like oh yeah you're doing
youtube that's one aspect of it
hollywood is another aspect like yeah
you've just got like this like huge kind
of like media platform
that's been sick thank you so much
absolutely wonderful yeah and we should
definitely keep in touch absolutely yeah
yeah thank you very much for coming on
um any any final ask to the audience
when they hear this appreciate the fact
that like if you're listening to this
you're probably in this immensely
influential position you live at this
very unusual time in history when we
have unprecedented opportunity to do
good if you're listening you may have
your whole career ahead of you as well
this is this huge opportunity to have a
contribution to one of the biggest
problems in the world so check out 80
000 hours read what we are the future or
my previous book doing good better and
uh yeah let's together try and do as
much good as we can amazing thank you so
much thank you